excellent
right
all right citizens of the reject Nation
you know what to do let us know if we
are live it is not a live streaming
already they know what to do to such a
level we're already even have to say it
y'all are on top of it appreciate you
also you know what else to do hit that
like hit that comment bar with whatever
word you want coming out of you hit that
share send it to your friends your
family your loved ones that neighbor you
don't know if you like or not you're
like maybe we'll Bond over this DC AMU
ranking video obscure video that might
bring us together closer than ever oh
we're gonna Bond today don't worry guys
it is all about the love we are a team
we are a league we are here for just
just koi thank you for enduring and for
championing this live stream thank you
guys for joining we will be answering
Super Chat is going to be a little bit
chaotic today because we are going to go
through we're gonna rank we're gonna
give a couple quick thoughts reviewing
each movie but uh we also want to get to
your super chats you guys drive the
conversation so send us your thoughts on
these films or just about anything you
want we're going to go through a few
movies at a time check in with you guys
then jump back so hopefully everybody
feels like they are involved so uh so
yeah you can hit up the Super Chat
there's also a link to stream Labs if
you would like to uh chip in in a way
their YouTube doesn't take quite as much
that's also very much appreciated and uh
just before we hop in properly uh I do
want to say a really huge and sincere
thank you to Greg who I know is just ex
can't wait to watch more of John and koi
two hours of us he's just tuning in
right now thrilled but seriously like
when again Greg
pitched this idea or you know came up
with this idea and was like I think I'm
gonna pair you and Coy together to do
these DC films like I was so excited at
the outset but this journey thus far and
getting to look forward to this every
week has become one of my absolute
favorite things to do here and it's been
so much fun you know journeying through
these movies and seeing what you know
the full potential of a shared Universe
like this can look like so just uh props
to Greg if you're you know on his social
media go give him a like or some love
because uh he's how this is happening
yeah we wouldn't be here if it weren't
for him and uh and yeah I'm ever
grateful for especially this little
series that we do totally agree uh I
want to dive into it as well but I do
want to say that this has helped me not
only get to know John better and our
eclectic musical taste and all of our
EXO synchronicities the word will come
to me but uh we've gotten to know each
other better and uh it's helped me love
animation better and it's helped me love
these characters already loved better so
this whole thing has been delightful so
I'm really excited to share that ranking
with you lovelies uh so expect uh for
for watch back later we're gonna do a
few go go to Super Chat do if you go to
Super Chat so we're gonna count down
because that's the way you do an
exciting uh ranking video by starting at
the bottom absolutely and getting into
it so if you want a question guaranteed
answered uh get in there and we will
attack all those super chats and
streamlabs as we go should we start with
number 16. well let's let's do it quick
shouts out TJ Selwyn in the chat yeah
gamer MJ Bruno Stellino 17 Sarah
Williamson ooh quickest twig twig list
twig I like a quick list twig twig list
twig Jackson right here Ragu always
holding it down Hugo
Scott Reyes Laurie Esquire in the chat
love to see all your shining faces and
the horror they added like
thanks guys all right well yes uh let's
get this road on the show uh before we
hop into some super chats let's do the
let's start at the bottom and now we're
here so koi I'm gonna put a few seconds
on the clock okay what is your number
16. now I've got a letterboxed account
where I've ranked these do you not think
I'm just texting I'm using my phone for
the powers of good not distraction sure
all right my number 16 of all is Justice
League War hey so we're starting out on
a like footage League War is my this is
already efficient this is this will save
us some time so let's just live on this
one Justice League War for me was a
little bit messy it was a little bit uh
contrived it felt right for me it didn't
understand the characters as I know them
uh now these are characters that mean a
lot to me these are characters that uh
are are thrown into this else world but
even within this else World it didn't
even feel like they were authentic to
the version of themselves that they set
them out to be like some of their
choices felt like they weren't quite
organic I did enjoy how much they were
able to put in this film but the
characterization threw me from being
like wow that writing is really
impressive how much they're able to do
but then when the characters didn't feel
like who they're supposed to be and some
of the characters they omitted that
would have worked better there was
enough messiness it's the bottom
absolutely see this is this is gonna be
great because you're already used to
like cramming a lot of thoughts into a
small you know needle of the the eye of
the needle and I'm going to be trying to
channel my koi today yes um but yeah no
I absolutely agree Justice League War
was fun but it's like the most sort of
slight of all of them to me in terms of
like character anything and yeah it's
like you've got this kind of odd take on
Superman and Wonder Woman where they're
both a little more sort of feisty than
I'm used to and uh yeah it's it's a fun
movie but it's easily the most like it
was about what I expected you know like
yeah it's them you know doing a Rock'em
sock'em kind of thing and it's fun but
there are so many other better examples
of really conscientious crossovers
handling a bunch of characters with a
plum and all that stuff so so yeah it
just there are I clearly liked every
Justice League title better than this
and to be clear this is to me this is
the one that's meh like I kind of tried
to to also gauge them by like meh pretty
good good great I love this right um and
so this is probably the only one I'd say
that is like truly like I've got like
one that that one is the only one I
wouldn't recommend to people the rest I
would actively recommend this is the
other one that's like iffy my number 15
is Teen Titans the Judas contract that
is awesome
being efficient guys crushing killing
the game all right my number 15 is Judas
contract because I did enjoy the Teen
Titans so much more in other capacities
and other mediums in other ways and I
did feel like of the villains this was
the weakest it felt a bit mustache
twirly it felt like it definitely yeah
blood was just like all right well I
guess he's a bad guy because he's a bad
guy like he just did bad guy stuff like
I didn't believe his motivations I
didn't quite justify any of his means
and the Teen Titans felt underserved
like they didn't feel like they got to
do any of the cool titans-ness uh so for
me it just didn't quite land and I liked
them too much to have them underserved
yeah and guys feel free as we are going
through these as we name each movie
perhaps you know number out where it
would rank for you
um and thank you so much to everybody
who's already jumped into the Super
chats we see you and uh we we will be
with you momentarily so keep those
thoughts and questions coming
um but yeah Judas contract to me was a
similar way there's a lot of stuff I
like about there are a lot of elements
that I like and I like a lot of the
guest voice cast and stuff it's nice to
have Christina Ricci
um but yeah it's just like all the
elements are kind of I don't know
there's something that didn't quite
coalesce about them I I felt like the
first Teen Titan Teen Titans movie in
this continuity just did everything this
one tried to do but better yeah and uh
yeah like having
um uh Tara
uh
uh uh uh not get quite the the amount of
juice you deserved for the story like I
feel like Tara was definitely a
character who has a beautiful Arc a
beautiful story and was played well but
they didn't really get to serve her
character while also juggling the other
disparate parts and I do think that was
largely in part of the villain feeling
kind of one note and and none of the
rest of the movies had a one note
villain to me yeah yeah it's just like
the villains feel underserved and all
the teens it's like you know the Beast
Boy relationship is like not really that
endearing it's like it's kind of pushy
and uh you know yeah there's a lot of
stuff that could have been better about
this so yeah that's my number 15 uh
kicking it over to number 14. we've got
for me Suicide Squad held up hang
awesome Suicide Squad hell to pay sounds
like our first difference of opinion uh
it is just not to me as good as the
other suicide squads my voice squeak
there I'm losing it uh my Suicide Squad
hell to pay experience was good but I
definitely enjoyed the other Suicide
Squad movie so much more that it showed
me like what the suicide squad can be
um I didn't feel like I was as invested
in these characters enough that when
they bit it I was like yo I'm Struck it
felt like they were very color by
numbers like well this character has to
go this character has to live this
character is going to make it this
character isn't
um it never it never pulled me into the
world as completely as it needed to it
was cool to see Bronze Tiger it was cool
to see you know uh Christian Slater play
Deadshot and a few of these characters
that made it higher than the other two
but this is still one that like if
someone's like oh would you recommend
the suicide squad hell to pay I'd say
like if you like suicide or if you like
like there'd be a caveat in my
recommendation so it puts it pretty
lower yeah that makes sense it's a
little higher for me but uh but there
you go all right all right uh okay so
number what are we on 14 that was 14 I
was number 14 okay so uh number 14 for
me was actually Justice League Throne of
Atlantis
um which I enjoyed I I reviewed all
these to the you know throughout the
week moving into this and uh Justice
League Throne of Atlantis was one that I
enjoyed again and I thought you know
that it was pretty good it
conscientiously I thought you know mixed
an Aquaman's story with the Justice
League story but I feel like the flavor
of this movie and it is called Justice
League but it sort of indicates that
like you know Aquaman is like barely
present throughout this entire thing
right and I feel like he's competing in
his own movie for some kind of
spotlighter to have that origin and so
uh yeah like there's so much this really
neat and interesting about Atlantis and
yet I feel like there are other movies
that kind of took us on that kind of
Journey a little bit better yeah so
while I really enjoyed especially having
like Batman and Superman like you know
kind of teaming up and investigating
detective working together uh yeah
there's just something about this one
that that yeah just there were again a
lot of elements that were better served
in other stories yeah I've got some of
my lenses a little higher but I also
agree with your qualms uh and someone in
the chat I saw say uh Suicide Squad felt
unnecessarily edgy and I was like that's
kind of that's kind of the vibe I had I
don't I don't use that word often but
this one did feel edgy to me uh let's do
one more and then get to the super
checks I feel like it's it's 16 so it's
perfect four rows of four yeah uh so my
number 13 the final one before we get
over the chats uh for me was Batman bad
blood okay uh my lowest Batman because I
did feel like it underserved Batman and
Robin and Talia and like Talia was like
weirdly just kind of there uh I didn't
really feel invested in heretic as much
as I wanted to even though I love Travis
Willingham I didn't really feel invested
in the family elements as much as I
wanted to but it was still freaking cool
so it's higher than the other ones
because it's still a Batman movie it's
still like got that awesome like gritty
Gravelly Nuance to it that Batman brings
when done well this is definitely like
now we've left them and we've gotten
into good and like it's just the rest of
me are good to Great to exceptional so
this one is good but I wouldn't re-watch
it I'm glad to have seen it
um I really did enjoy uh the the missing
element of Batman and having uh you know
Nightwing and Robin cover form that was
a really cool element because I enjoy
that that storyline in the comic books
but to me it just couldn't be higher
because this is more a case of the other
12 urges better this one's not bad it's
just the other 12 or better absolutely I
would agree with that and I ranked it
the same spot as you there's I was just
fantastic I was because there's so many
of these two that I debated on and I
like flipped and flopped but yeah like
this one and I remember remember us
talking about it on the actual video
feeling like uh an episode out of a TV
show more than any of the other ones and
yeah like I like Cassandra Kane uh and
and having you know a broader bat family
but like even those characters don't
really ever come back until the end uh
so yeah it's like there was a lot of fun
about it and I did like the whole like
oh Bruce has been kidnapped and they're
experimenting on him but even that I
thought could have you know been made
into something greater
um so it has a lot of the fun but you
want I think a certain amount of I don't
know interesting heft out of it that I
don't think you quite got necessarily I
agree that's that's definitely where I'm
at with that okay so same page all right
let's get to some super chats let's
stream them let's hop in alrighty
alrighty Wally brings that up I want to
apologize for being late you guys this
was entirely my fault I had my wires
crossed on timing so I bought Hoy you
just live to destroy it's on me that's
who you are that's why it Rhymes it
means it must be true absolutely man
don't worry but uh yeah guys leave your
uh rankings as we go through these
because uh you know we we want to hear
your thoughts as well we want to hear
what you uh because this has been a
journey and then two like seeing the
comments throughout has been really fun
because everybody has such a different
flavor and a different take and and a
different sort of side of the universe
that appeals to them
um but yeah let's hop into here with the
first Super Chat of the day from Johnny
hold on a sec hold on a sec super chats
not Vengeance that's right clever that's
right question one from Johnny uh
shouldisi IM and image release low to
mid budget animated films theatrically
and question number two should we get a
live ranking of Nolan next weekend
now that would be fun uh you know I love
me some Nolan sure uh but uh your boys
on strike uh so I got to be careful with
which things I can div into and discuss
so uh this being an animated video and
this being about films uh from before
the strike it was a different thing um I
don't think I can talk about Oppenheimer
or anything else for a while but uh I do
love Nolan so maybe the other Nolan
films that'd be very frustrating be like
how does that one rank I don't know yet
all right I mean that's where I'm at I
would love to that that sounds really
fun I mean we have you know there's
there's an array of things to figure out
what all these strikes happening but
yeah I mean a Nolan ranky would be a
blast second favorite director yeah and
that's one of the few directors I feel
like I would be equipped to right I've
seen everything he's done I actually
have opinions yeah and there are enough
of them but not too many of them to
where it's not super of course easy
ranking is a bit prohibitive uh and then
the first question
um do you see an image is
okay so a mid-budget
what's hard about animation is when it's
cheap it looks cheap and mid budget is a
very tricky term because I feel like
theatrically would just show uh any
flaws bigger so I would love that for
the companies I'd love that for the
exposure I'd love that for all those
things but I really think they need to
put some money behind theatrically
animated films like mask of the Phantasm
like like uh you know Teen Titans Go
they need to be quality as much as I
don't want these budgets to keep
exploding I think whatever that looks
like you know 100 million dollar
spider-verse movie made a lot of profit
versus a 300 million dollar Indiana
Jones movie so I think that's a a tricky
situation um so we'll see but at the
same time I do want more people to
discover these characters so as long as
it can be done in a way that's quality
I'd love to see it yeah and I think
that's the thing is is with uh animation
you know
part of me is like yeah release the
mid-budget stuff theatrically and and
you know because I'm all for that you
know exhibition experience but at the
same time I'm like
but you know animation I think needs to
be you know supported and given its
resources to truly shine and Thrive and
so I feel like you might be setting a
movie up to not shine as brightly if
you're putting a mid-budget animation up
on a big screen but you know it depends
on how good the animation is yeah you
know and how good the storytelling is
because you can get away with a a lot
you know with good storytelling I would
I would certainly argue yeah I agree um
so yeah I would be I would be curious
certainly I would be happy to see them
Embrace that more certainly like I would
have watched happily any of these films
on a big screen also there's tons of
Image Comics that would not work as well
live action yes yeah of course uh and oh
my goodness I would be very curious to
to hear a little slate of what English
Comics would work but let's move on to
uh real Eric Eric
super chats not Vengeance that's right
just got home from work and super tired
it's okay we're here to put you to sleep
talking right out ranking right it's
like a lullaby uh and I wanted to thank
koi for the tips on making and writing
reviews it's helped out a lot of you
guys oh what are your tips koi my tips
are to actually believe in what you're
saying you have to actually love this
stuff and don't uh just be negative for
the sake being negative it's going to be
more popular be negative it's going to
be uh you're going to do better faster
being negative but it'll rot your soul
so if you think about stuff negatively
all the time it's like the yellow car
thing right so if you buy a yellow car
suddenly you'll notice yellow cards if
you buy a Jeep Wrangler suddenly in
those Jeep Wranglers if you start making
your life about negativity I guarantee
you your life gets more negative so I
don't know how critics do it uh I know
being a Critic doesn't necessarily mean
negative but I know it does it requires
you to critique art in a way that would
rob me personally of some love of art so
people that are hyper critical people
that aren't even critics that are just
critical of things their lives must suck
so uh I think finding joy in all things
I think looking to what you're
passionate about and I think I told this
person that you need to make sure that
it's it's a passion that is something
you're willing to do for free for long
enough that by the time it gets to get
paid it's like oh man I would have kept
doing that for free but thank God I
don't have to so uh just be be so
zealous before you even commit to it and
know that it's you're doing it because
you love it not because uh everyone else
is doing it or because you want to do
it's got to be like the only thing you
can do
that's beautiful advice coediferous so
that's how I see it I appreciate you oh
and looky here we got a super sticker
from Dart car hold on a sec ooh we get
to play a different sound why did you
set that Super Chat there you go I like
that one quite a bit and we got a fist
bump I appreciate you Dart car all right
and then last one and then we'll go back
to the other four I like these four four
four on the floor it's a good uh it's a
classic beat it's a classic Rhythm
structure oh here we go here we go let's
do uh let's do
Super Chat yes raccoon in there I knew I
knew it happened there had to be there
had to be then that was the thing is is
sourcing quotes for this it actually
helped because I reviewed all of our
reactions as kind of prep I feel like
you have all these things stored in your
head I got a weird brain and I was like
I need to revisit all of these so I uh
yeah I was like this will give me an
ample opportunity to find you know some
quotes that stand out from this
particular franchise if we've met and I
forget your name it's because I keep all
this stored in there there's only so
much space yes it's all for uh for movie
details and ranking notes raccoon
shampoo thank you so much for
contributing to the super chats uh
what's one thing you want to see gun
take from the DC AMU the driving yes
every movie the drive to begin on a city
street all of the DCU must begin with
someone driving or flying or
transporting yes I need to see
Transportation whether it's speed boat
car I want everything to open with a
high speed chase through Metropolis
Coast City Gotham I got terms uh what do
I want to see gun taking the DC AMU I
want to see him take the ability to
introduce characters in a way that is
fully fleshed out and Trust the audience
but also doesn't underserve the
character I think one of the best things
about the DC AMU is that the immediacy
of us being endeared to these characters
doesn't change movie to movie it does a
really good job going hey here's a small
scene that tells you everything about
them the best movies like the opening
scene usually is a great through line of
the entire film I think the DC AMU did
that exceptionally so bringing that
cohesiveness over to where you're like
oh I love that character you don't have
to totally reintroduce them again I
trust you uh because there are
archetypal characters in here so the
trust for the audience and the ability
to tell big stories very quickly yeah
absolutely I mean I think James Gunn is
really I think he's really well attuned
to bringing in obscure characters and
lots of characters and having it feel
natural and having it feel like yeah
this is just one big organization of
people who all happen to be dealing with
this particular problem and it's like I
remember the days of like the MCU
figuring out how to cross over how to
incorporate like the broader Universe in
these micro installments without it
feeling intrusive or having it feel you
know uh shoehorned or anything like that
and so I feel like yeah we'll certainly
get that uh uh Whimsy of like oh here's
a character I wasn't expecting like this
journey through the dcamu has given me a
couple new favorites that I didn't I was
none the wiser of beforehand that's cool
um and so yeah I feel like he'll have a
strength uh for that certainly and I
feel like yeah he will be able to give
us all the fun and the bounce of these
things without skewing too silly and
while still giving us that emotional
like the best of these always manage to
be like tight and Punchy but not
sacrificing the emotion and I feel like
he's been doing this long enough to have
that level of efficiency but also that
level of like emotional and he loves the
comics so it'll show yeah and I saw a
couple people in the chat we are not
done with DC animated we're done with DC
AMU which is why we're ranking these we
got more DC animated to go and we got
another one dropping next week so we we
got stuff coming for you guys uh so by
all means please do not think this is
the end it is the beginning-ish it took
uh yeah yeah yeah it took a a while just
to realize that this was its own
continuity yeah and so uh yeah so we
will certainly be back with more DC
animated and sooner than you would
imagine even as you're watching this
today but yes koi what number are we out
we are at number 12 we are into the
penultimate row now we're going up uh
okay my number 12 this may be
controversial because now we're into the
good but something's got to be low in
the good so here we are The Death of
Superman okay uh I enjoyed the hell out
of this know that uh The Death of
Superman was handled very well I was
actually really impressed with it uh as
compared to its live action counterpart
uh the only reason this and the next one
didn't swap is I do feel like The Death
of Superman is a story that's been told
um a number of times and I do feel like
this is the best telling of it but I did
feel like there were elements that uh
felt um
not color by numbers but going through
the motions there were moments that felt
like the emotional earned beat was
because I had already felt it before so
I had a hard time judging this one
because I'm so familiar with it now
that's not this movie's fault but I'm
acknowledging that someone that hasn't
read the story known the story
experience the story might put it higher
that's that's my only caveat that being
said it's very high up because I really
enjoyed Rebecca Rebecca Romaine is Lois
Lane I love Ren Wilson as Lex I really
think Jerry O'Connell's Clark shines
here this one is exceptional it just
can't be higher because I did feel
moments of like I know this story too
well to really know what I'm
experiencing this way sure so this is my
own problem okay interesting I wonder
what you might have flip-flopped it with
and I wonder if it was what I was
debating here yeah because for my uh
again you'll you'll be our numerology
guy what number are we on we're third
this was 12. this was 12. for me number
12 at the moment that's the other thing
is is informing this list almost every
option I was like man I can flip-flop
this one I can flip-flop this one and
like I've been rearranging this list the
entire time up until this point so this
is just my list yeah I went through
today yeah this is just as of today here
and now but my number 12 would be Son of
Batman at the moment I really like Son
of Batman and sort of Batman beginsy
kind of way and I think the only reason
I put it here is because it is like the
start of something that's only going to
get that much greater each time and this
feels like an installment that you do
have to weather a little bit to get to
the the benefits and the Really
endearing aspects of the Bruce Wayne and
Damien relationship like seeing this
movie I was like okay I'm here for
Damien and the potential of Damien but I
can also see why he's not maybe
everyone's favorite Robin why he's maybe
a little controversial Robin I get the
scrappy do factor and the fact that you
really have to break through the outer
you know hardened shell of this kid
who's been raised in the League of
Shadows and all that
um and so yeah it was one of those
things where I was like I really like
this this is really straight in its
intent in the story it's telling it
almost has that Batman man begins
quality because you are seeing so much
of you know Raz al Ghul's side of the
world yeah um race algol I should say
um and yeah like it's a it's a solid one
but again it's like when I think of it I
think of the lovely and wonderful
developments that come after it totally
totally fair so that's kind of why I put
that there and now I'm curious as to
what what your next one yeah because
this is there could be a day-to-day swap
so those uh these last three have been
three star films uh I gave I personally
gave Justice League War Judas contract
and held to pay two and a half Stars
I've given Batman Bad Blood The Death of
Superman and this next one and the next
one after this three stars this is a
three-star film okay Batman hush uh I
could have swapped Batman hush and Death
of Superman
um Batman hush did something interesting
where it completely changed the twist
it did so in a way that I doubted my
memory and I actually want to get a
credit for that because I love Batman
hush and I was like I know how this ends
and then it ended in a way that I was
like am I wrong and it was kind of nice
to be like wait a second did I change
the ending myself now I'm not going to
give away either ending because maybe
you haven't seen them but I did at least
appreciate the fact that it did the
opposite of Death of Superman where my
death of Superman experience went was I
know this so well that I feel like I'm
missing out on a new experience as
though I'm enjoying this the Batman hush
experience was like I love Batman hush
am I wrong so like so the only reason
that one's higher than the other is
because at least my brain went like what
a novel approach I thought the animation
was solid I really like that they made a
different style of animation for Batman
hush I really enjoyed the Catwoman
Batman stuff I really appreciated how
much they utilized the comic book
storyline how much of the greatest hits
of his villains that storyline is from
you know the Jim Lee Comics but I do
want to say I don't think Batman hush
doesn't necessarily a better film but
from my experience that those are the
reason these could swap any day so
that's number 11 for me okay all right
not bad not bad my number 11 was your
number 12. it was the death of Superman
very close yeah absolutely and The Death
of Superman to me was one where yeah I
felt like this happens every so often
with especially these kinds of movies
where I feel like there is sometimes I'm
the goal is to be swept up in just this
story and fully focused on that and
sometimes I'll find myself sitting
watching something and going I feel like
this is a version of this but not the
version of this and yeah Death of
Superman had a lot of good things going
for it I I liked it as a Superman story
better than what some of the earlier
installments hail the Superman story to
maybe be
um and the big thing this one was sort
of missing for me was just that that
warmth of Superman that warmth of Clark
and I don't dislike the take like I'm
I'm open to the new idea that like oh
he's been with Diana and now he's with
Lois and this is all new to him and he's
having trouble opening up and and
putting her in that asking her to
embrace that danger but at the same time
I don't know having him being like so
averse to having her meet mon yeah there
was stuff like that but I was like
that's not Superman there's whis yeah
it's like it has good wistful Melancholy
tones and it has like that heart it's
like when the actual sacrifice comes
down you do feel the weight of that and
you do feel the Paul that that casts
however uh yeah I feel like if we had
really felt that warmth and if we had
built the Lois and Clark relationship up
over multiple like this is an example of
a movie that does nicely to continue
building the stakes of the Apocalypse
War uh and it you know gradually laces
that in throughout and this is another
good example of that whereas I feel like
the lowest Diana Clark triangle could
have been way better served up till this
point because it still feels like death
of Superman in one movie is trying to do
all this emotional language I totally
agree and I'd forgotten about that was a
problem I had to I've forgotten the
lowest element it was like wait what
what now it's happening okay yeah so I'm
like I like having a love story that I
can like you know get behind a little
bit but also you know I would like to
really love these two more than feeling
like I got to develop all that right now
totally yeah totally great yeah I'm
right there with you uh so my number
10 was already set by you my personal
number 10 is throne of Atlantis okay I
agree with a lot of what you had to say
I definitely this is a three-star film
for me
um but I definitely feel like it is one
that could have been better if it was an
Aquaman movie uh it definitely is a
Justice League Atlantis movie and that
definitely you know affected my
experience of it because we didn't
really get an Aquaman experience and
like Aquaman is a character that is an
important member of the Justice League I
understand that he's not the most
popular but if you're going to have him
as a formative member you really need to
make a movie for him and you may notice
Batman Superman Constantine there's all
these characters but like where's
Aquaman it's literally a Justice League
Throne of Atlantis and it felt like that
so one of the things I commended at the
top of this was what I want James gonna
bring over is giving everyone their due
I don't feel like sideburns Aquaman God
is due uh we see sideburns Aquaman a lot
and we also made fun of Hawkman not
getting to talk I feel like cyber and
Aquaman kind of got the leading version
of Hawkman where it's like you got a lot
of time don't know what you did and then
like that started to affect me so it's
not lower because my issues with Batman
hush was you know changing an iconic
ending in a way that made me at least go
like huh but like not loving it
um death Superman my my lowest issues
that John shared all the rest of them
had big problems Justice League Throne
of Atlantis it's not telling me it's an
Aquaman movie if this was called Aquaman
Throne of Atlantis it'd be at the bottom
because it's not an Aquaman movie but
the problem I have with it is it's a
lacking into the whole thing that this
is the best Band-Aid for but still not
quite a fully served movie so I can't
put it any higher it makes the top 10
but only barely uh and the rest of them
are three and a half and up so this is
my last of the good and it's about to
get great yeah yeah and that one too
just the last to put the final nail on
Throne of Atlantis you two have that
idea that like you've got Aquaman of
Steel from most of the movie and then at
the end when he's Aquaman now he's like
hey I'm I'm just like a happy guy now
wow like a wholesale other character now
yeah he's like the same voice actor
doing a different character yeah 100
yeah so yeah that's that's how I felt
okay yeah Fair enough all right uh top
nine top nine what was your ten though
my number ten okay here we go I've been
I'm still no it's not good it's all good
that's why I'm here all right I'm just
gonna go with the gut I feel like this
might be a little bit blasphemy but my
number 10 was reign of the Superman whoa
I quite is that too low no it's just
mine well mine's only three spots higher
it's just I'm surprised okay okay
there's some spoilers for next round
there are some surprises here I mean I I
just remember our emotional investment
now but I'm not I'm not saying you're
wrong you know what I might change it on
the Fly oh okay I'm not I'm not changing
I'm not trying to change you I'm just
surprised I made this list and I was
like I feel like like there should be
one more Notch between I just remember
you being like
and all the Supermen yeah so I'm just
surprised at you right now but again I'm
not trying to change it I I don't
there's no wrong here it's your
experience audience you know what I'll
you know I'm gonna stick with this sick
of your guns I I really liked this and
the thing is in reviewing it I liked it
even I I liked it progressively as it
went along I think me and Terry Ann made
the same face uh see that's the thing is
is it's I really liked it and it it gets
better for me as it goes and I really
like this sort of fun like that's the
thing is now we're to a point where like
it's so hard to start ranking and it's
like each of them I've got a different
reason for appreciating sure and I'm
thinking on like that's the thing is to
explain the criteria I tried to think of
like what the definitive criteria for
ranking should be and I was like I don't
know man like some of these are doing
really well and just like a story
technical level some of them are doing
well on an emotional level some of them
are doing all these different things uh
Serena the Superman I really really
liked and I think gets better and better
as it goes and I think the array of
Supermen that they had was really nice
and the thing that this movie gets
really right is that when Superman
himself returns with the mullet and the
black suit you do feel like hope has
returned you do feel like there is uh
there's just a catharsis and and just
like a you know a swell that comes when
he is back it's got good Justice League
moments Lois and Diana getting to know
each other in the wake of Clark's death
I think is a really nice thing
um there is that bit where them all just
kind of standing there as the boom tube
Falls that I still think is like really
kind of silly um but yeah I think this
one does really nicely in the yeah hope
comes back to the room I think it's a
significant step up from what came
before it yeah um I just yeah I wish
that there was again more of that I keep
feeling like we almost got there with
Superman because we spend so much time
on Batman Batman's like the main
character of his own movies in so many
respects and I still feel like Superman
is like fighting to be the main
character in his own movie but what I
liked about this one is that yeah you
have this idea of like when Superman's
gone who Was Gonna Fill the spot a bunch
of these semis yeah yeah so I really do
like that and on a different day I might
put it higher it's just yeah today I was
this is what my priorities were guns
yeah I respect it I was like don't
change because I don't know I don't know
what's going to move just like there's
there's stuff I might put on sooner but
you never know yeah yeah I enjoyed
watching that with you because how well
I know that story and how much you were
like this is happening yeah uh okay my
number nine our last one of this round
my personal number nine John has already
had so we've had very similar lists so
far okay Son of Batman
um Son of Batman it's my first three and
a half star which puts it in the like
good to Great like it's almost great
it's right on the edge of great I guess
they're like four stars like great this
is like good great uh meaning it's got
so much more right than wrong but it
definitely didn't feel
it felt short and a lot of these don't
feel short a lot of these feel like
they're the right run time I definitely
found myself being like okay sometimes
this feels slow sometimes this feels
fast the pacing was off for me where I
was like I'm invested I'm I'm not
invested I'm too invested I want to slow
down so uh some of the Batman like it's
hold a very great story I love the Talia
relationship and I didn't feel like the
Talia Batman relationship was shown
strong enough in this to Warrant the
story like without Talia and Batman
working Damien doesn't work and without
Damien working the bat family doesn't
work and without the bad family working
Nightwing doesn't work like yeah there's
just the big Crux of it didn't quite
land so even though the rest was great
that definitely affected my experience
because I definitely feel like with
Talia and Batman you need to believe
their love even if you know the way
Damien was conceived is a little sketchy
but you've got to believe that like
Batman can ever fall for and I never was
like she's a villain she's leaving like
there was always a weird I don't know
the whole DC AMU tree to tell you weird
so the most I saw that this was the best
installment for her though sure until
she pieces out on that boat
so yeah that I can't put it higher
because of that element but it is a good
movie sure okay yeah I'm with you I feel
you that's nine what's your nine what's
my nine my nine right now as of today is
Suicide Squad hell to pay see this is
the thing I really like this this was a
breath of fresh air and this was one of
the ones to me that had that quality
that like a JL dark has where it feels
like wow we are definitely in the same
universe but we were in a very different
side of the universe and I feel like
this movie is doing what you would hope
a good exploitation movie would do
because it's very much borrowing from
exploitation movies it's in that style I
think that fits really well but it's
doing that thing well and it's also
doing just a little more than you
thought it would I think it has one of
the best macguffins like ever because
you actually like it's useful you care
about it it doesn't really matter what
it is but at the same time it makes
sense as to why everyone's chasing it
and I think it's a really nice way to do
a surprise sequel to Flashpoint yeah
with all the zoom stuff I found that
really gripping and even though it gets
a little overwhelming with uh you've got
uh
Vandal and Scandal Savage and all that
stuff happening and you got Professor
Pig and you've got like all these
different things uh yeah I just feel
like they managed to balance the pulp
with the fun road trip Vibe and then
having this sort of like dual I don't
know I really like the whole Floyd
Lawton and um and Bronze Tiger back and
forth because they are like the yin and
the Yang of leadership of The Suicide
Squad uh Christian Slater and Vanessa
Williams I think are great I love the
twist of Waller having a personal use
for this Mission yeah so it's got all
the suicide squad stuff but it's got
like these surprising character elements
I love Copperhead uh and just yeah like
the new characters and things like that
that they would give us so uh yeah this
just left a big impression on me and
again I feel like what you want from an
exploitation movie is that pulp that fun
and that edgy grimy you know it's
violent it's rated R but also I think
this is just you know doing more than it
needed to do and it's succeeding at that
stuff too I love it I love that taken I
love the red trip elements that one yeah
all right I I don't disagree with
anything you had to say about his nine
uh let's get into some super chats and
streamlabs shall we do that Super's last
time in our check stream first this time
check the streamlibs and thank you guys
for for keeping our little talk on uh
track and uh structured moving and
grooving today you could be anywhere on
a Sunday but you're here with us I
appreciate that I mean you know you
could be born on a Monday could be and
boy oh boy did that recently come to
play which uh no all of my top my top uh
five is just all the ones that Grundy
appeared in that's yeah yeah spoiler
alert for later in the chat that's the
life hack all right oh and thank you so
much guys we've already got a fair
amount of super chat or uh uh stream Lab
contributions there is a pinned link it
is the correct one uh good Greg has made
sure of it uh we would like again thank
you to Greg for putting this together
like I'm so grateful I didn't know how
this stream would go and I feel like you
know already this has been you know at
least more sort of popping than I
expected so thank you guys for joining
us and thank you to Greg for for again
gifting us with one of the best you know
experiences the fun runs we've had just
such a journey and uh and and coming to
know these characters and stories more
intimately through this process has been
like a real gift and a joy to me so uh
and I wouldn't have had time to watch
him otherwise I'm not gonna lie yeah so
uh so thank you again to go go shower
Greg and likes and things because uh
yeah it's it's all his design
um but Sammy boy Sammy boy hold up hold
up hold up
there you go it's back I found it
interesting the Superman and Wonder
Woman relationship thought Injustice was
the only Universe are they a thing in
the comics and do they have a super kid
and is apocalypse wore an original or is
there a second flash point in the comics
okay so Injustice is definitely a a side
verse I'm glad you found the other it
sounds like sense
um I I don't personally see Superman and
Wonder Woman together in many universes
I think it is it is kind of like an
elseworldly decision that happens in the
more darker edgier ones because it's a
way to make them both darker
um they do have those moments in the
elseworld stuffs in the comics you're
asking if they have a thing uh I don't
think there is a kid I I can't think of
any storyline where there's a Wonder
Woman Superman kid there might be
there's a lot of elseworlds I don't want
to speak to all of comic books but not
to my immediate knowledge and your last
question is uh a second flash point in
the comics there's the main flash point
but the idea of a Flashpoint is a lot
like an Infinite Crisis where it can
kind of restart things so I think in
elseworld there might be other flash
points but if you think of comet
continuity the flashpoint is the
singular entity I hope that makes sense
it makes sense to me koi because you've
watched all these DC animated films
absolutely I mean I feel like I haven't
learned a lot from this experience and
Sammy boy once again why did you set
that super jacket I was wondering in the
DC Universe what are Greek gods what are
the Greek gods are they aliens like as
guardians or is the DC Universe God's
confirmed to be Greek and is that the
religion of the DC or is it an mcu-like
system where all of them exists on other
planes of the afterlife so I definitely
know the Marvel structure more um in
this case especially like the afterlife
and and all those elements that's
definitely what I'm more used to I don't
actually know uh I feel like Hercules is
in both Marvel and DC because it was a
character whose rights had expired and
became public domain like there are
certain things that are just like we can
use this character
um as far as like the way they're seen
I've never fallen into the
um they're in Alien so they have powers
thing I know some writers like to do
that I feel like continuity changes so
much there is no real answer here I I
know that's a non-answer answer but some
writers like to make God's aliens some
writers like to make aliens God some
writers like to make this element of the
story Supernatural when it wasn't so
this is kind of like depending on who's
writing it is the answer there's not
really a a main Canon to my knowledge of
what gods are to DC that I know of
because there's also the old gods are
your Zeus that made you know uh Wonder
Woman out of play that are you know the
ones you've heard of the Greeks but
there's also the new guts who are
characters I love like Mr miracle and uh
dark side you know there's grainy
goodness there's a lot of gods so I
think it depends on the writer um
someone in the chat yeah it's the DC
version of Greek gods are dark side of
the new Gods so yeah there's different
like tears of gods and like they're
called different stuff because it
depends on how it's going absolutely
good crash course koi and you know what
I actually found out in in just going
over you know all this stuff and notes
is um
or was it jmd Matthias he wrote a number
of these and wanted to do like a new
Gods movie in this continuity and and
yeah it just never came to fruition but
you know he also wrote craving the last
hunt he's a good writer
look out Craven trailer reaction up on
the channel go check it out people all
right we got one from Sani or Sonny
depending on your pronunciation there
why did you said that super chat if
Superman Legacy and thank you for
contributing BT dubs uh if Superman
Legacy won't be a full origin story I
would like James Gunn to make an
animated movie or a short of the journey
Superman had to get to Legacy I get
people have seen it before but to feel
for a rebooted Universe you have to act
like this is one of two let's go up to
your other go there we go you gotta feel
like someone's first Superman and
doesn't know anything also hope gun will
integrate actors a lot with the animated
movies so it doesn't feel like we missed
the character for years to see him in a
sequel uh and is bright where is
brightburn uh now an elseworld's story
I mean okay there's there's a lot to
unpack here let's get that up on the
screen okay
um I feel like that's part of before you
take it away by that means please I I
feel like that's definitely part of the
the game plan James Gunn laid down was
that the animated characters would be
carrying over from live action and all
that stuff would be interconnected we'll
see you know when they have to use
standard voices or not Allah something
like what if but I feel like that is
their uh intent right now and uh
brightburn is the new Superman origin
story and he just goes to a lot of
therapy yep yep um but Jackson done is
the young
um David Corn sweat so uh it's Canon
here get it here first there you go but
yeah I mean do you think that for the
rebooted Universe would you want to see
some kind of animated origin or do you
feel like we're already we don't need
that personally I think we've seen I
mean I feel I personally I feel like the
guy Planet blew up he got here like
there's so much that we know about
Superman origin I understand what you're
saying I I get what you're saying as far
as like it's New Canon we need to see it
again but
I I personally think some characters
Origins are so much part of like the
Canon of our society we don't need to
see them reintegrated into a new Canon
because they're part of us like we know
the story so I personally wouldn't I
would much rather see as you said in
your second part I'd rather see them put
that animation budget and time into
connecting dots that we have I would I
would much rather see them not take four
years between a sequel
um and and make it the animated movie go
there then start in the beginning
because we do have that so clearly so if
Superman Legacy comes out in 2025 they
don't have time to do a Superman Legacy
2 or whatever they're gonna call it
until 2029. I'd rather see the 2027
movie Not Be An Origin I'd rather see it
be another story so personally I think
that story has been well tread
um but I I see what you're saying
absolutely I get that wanna do this one
last one and then we'll uh head back
let's do it Lone Wolf FX hold on hold on
hold on all right all right all right
why did you said that oh wait wait this
is I wanted this one okay super chats
not vengeance it's a good one there you
go hey rejects been watching you for
years but the first time on live stream
glad to be here I forgot to have you
welcome thank you for joining in the
conversation and for being so generous
um and yeah uh glad to be here my
favorite DC animated films are under the
Red Hood which is a banger was the first
one we watched and it was
I sat down and the first thing I
realized was oh yeah we don't get to
include that yeah we started this we
started Journey that is not in this with
two bangers and and one is is fodder for
this list and the other one is not and
also my number one of all the DC
Animated Universe films not DC animated
movie Universe the DC animated films
isn't in this my number one of all
you know what it is it's got a lot of
pizza yes oh I was hoping when we do our
top all of them uh we'll see if that one
holds the number one spot but my number
one spot is uh stairs to lose boy hey
man it's the sewers Vanilla Ice rap that
was that was such a good such a joke
Suicide Squad but yeah that's my number
one that didn't make a list so so DC
animated films under Red Hood uh
favorite uh DC animated are under the
Red Hood Batman year One which we have
not watched yet uh and Flashpoint city
of demons and I can't forget Batman
beyond return the Joker I recommend it I
remember when that came out I don't
think I ever saw it though I I think I
saw
I don't remember it I think I saw if it
went to theaters I think I saw it but I
know I saw him ask of the Phantasm and
there's like three movies I don't think
I've seen the Mr Freeze one and I don't
remember Return of the Joker if I've
seen it like I feel like I might have
but it was when it came out oh good and
I was a wee lad so yeah very excited uh
to ReDiscover if not discover yeah
absolutely I love Batman Beyond but yeah
these are these that you've listed here
are all great and yeah yeah some of them
are gonna be on this list in uh just a
mo in fact
um but yeah I mean this is a great
quality list here and guys by all means
I mean we are ranking the dcamu today
the animated movie Universe it took us
ages to figure out that that's what the
acronym was but leave your favorites of
all the DC animated movies because
chances are we've already covered one or
two of them or we're gonna get some nice
anticipation from your guys enthusiasm
to move forward but yeah thank you Lone
Wolf thank you very much as we
transition back hit that like button
because boy oh boy there's a lot of you
in here and there's not enough likes to
show the amount I see we see the number
to you in here and we see the number of
likes we'd like those closer together
absolutely hit that like we don't mind
we appreciated all right let's go back
over to the glory that is the d c a m u
m coming in at number eight yeah let's
let's I I did the bottom half starting
off you do the top half start oh number
eight for you good sir we'll pivot oh
cause we're out of 16 we're in the top
half we're in the top eight I'm in the
I'm in the hot seat now now leave a like
for the top eight people pressure okay
let's jump back into the list
my number eight drum roll
is uh this yes the thing is meant like
that's this was again a hard list
because there are like ones where I'm
like this one up the list I would rank
lower than this one down the list but in
the overall yeah this was really hard
but my number eight right now is Wonder
Woman Bloodlines I really really liked
this movie and this gave me what I kind
of wanted from the Aquaman one while
also giving me a really nice portrait of
Diana as a character to redefine her
after meeting her or After experiencing
her Injustice League War which again
she's got that sort of like I'm charged
up to fight yeah kind of vibe and I
thought this really nicely represented
her personality I really liked this
stuff with
um oh God what is it the damn it what is
her name the girl who becomes you know
sort of entangled in all of this uh what
is her name uh yeah yeah who has the
Wings by the end yeah
um yeah I just really liked uh the
mascara and the debate of that and
Diana's Journey throughout this the fact
that this Silver Swan Vanessa petalus
yeah that sounds about right I remember
Vanessa I don't remember the capitalists
yeah and I'm sorry interrupted I liked
having your Consortium of like Dr poison
and and uh yeah and and uh you know just
the codery of villains and and female
Rogues at that uh I thought the story
moved really gracefully I like the
character portrait we got of Diana and
yeah like this gave me the exploration
and the sort of themiskirin uh aesthetic
the way I kind of wanted to feel more at
home in and exploring Atlantis while
splitting the difference with our world
and and the tension of that and you know
Diana ultimately coming back and earning
the respect and everything yeah I just
thought this was like really graceful
and and breezed like an actual movie to
tease
this is the biggest gap between us
really Wonder Woman where you have one
this is the first time we've been more
than three apart oh my God first time
but I'm saying I'm keeping track I've
got a whole schematics in here it can
only be higher that math now uh but more
than three is the biggest disparate uh
distance now my number eight is Batman
versus Robin which I really enjoyed this
is my first four star film now we're out
of the three and a half run of the four
these are the greats for perspective I
only have one four and a half star in
this entire list so the rest of these
are four until my number one leave a
like for greatness because it's great
and also that certain Turtle movie the
four and a half star the movie's match
uh no okay Batman versus Robin I really
really dug because to me this really
showed Damien Wayne this really showed
why I love this character I love the
elements with Talon I love that Talon
genuinely felt like an other Batman like
I feel like they always do the villain
is a lot like if things went wrong from
your hero you got Iron Man Iron Monger
you've got like a Thor and Loki there's
this Trope of look at your mirror self
Logan did it very literally and had like
you know Wolverine Logan fighting a
version himself that was like off the
leash kind of you know a reflection this
I thought with Talos did a really good
job were you almost sympathized with her
tell us was coming from to the point
where you're like man Talent oh if I
keep saying Talos he's not a stroll too
oh that's why because secret invasions
uh but Talon I really enjoyed um because
it was so well fleshed out it made me
believe Damien believing in him usually
when there's like why is that young boy
falling for that impressionable clear
super villain it wasn't it was like
actually an investable story uh I really
loved again how Alfred and Batman's
relationship grew out of the court of
owl's element this to me was one of
those like such a good Batman story now
maybe it's my Batman bias but I really
think Batman vs Robin is the first of
them it's the lowest but it's the first
of these to be great
absolutely cool my number eight I agree
with you that's a great pick it might be
on my list somewhere I mean I I hope so
all right my my next one I was surprised
I thought I was going to rank this lower
in fact
um and and in revisiting it I was just
sitting there going ah man though this
is this has got the this got something
man like Batman hush I feel like is even
though the Twist and the journey of the
book is probably better overall okay I
will say that this movie just pulled me
right in with the sort of what I view to
be a sort of classic Batman kind of
feeling where I really felt the aura of
Gotham I loved loved the back and forth
between him and Selena and the fact that
you've got these parallel relationships
between Selena Kyle and Bruce Wayne and
Batman and Catwoman and you have her
starting out in this position of being a
rogue and then slowly snapping out of
poison ivy spelling and you know
becoming Bruce's Ally uh throughout
these things and that real debate coming
down to the ultimate factor of you know
that that ending beat of why they can't
be together because he couldn't stand to
you know even take out this most sort of
uh yeah like he couldn't stand to
execute this one guy who clearly
deserves it and that being sort of
indicative of their line yeah um but
yeah I thought it just had good fun use
of the Rogues good Bane and Poison Ivy
and stuff like that um I like the
Superman subplot with him uh you know
being all sort of he's like possessed
yeah right yeah like I thought that was
a really nice bit there uh Harley and
the Joker being framed and having that
whole device of or Joker Being Framed
for the death of uh Thomas uh and and
Elliot and being sort of I love that
Dynamic of everyone being like I want to
take credit I would do this but I didn't
do this yeah I just thought that was so
much fun and while yeah the twist in the
comics is a bigger shoe drop I did think
that the the choice grew on me basically
to have Riddler who I remember you
saying at the time that hush would have
come out would have been kind of maybe
more of a c-lister anyway he certainly
had his profile as a character rise over
time and so for me here I was like I
kind of like the fact that you get to
have if you're familiar at all with the
story then that moment of like wait a
minute this is this isn't what I
remember it's like that caught me but
then the explanation
while you're taken aback at first like I
thought it was actually kind of decent
and I liked the idea of the Riddler
really kind of wanting to transcend his
station and really kind of grab Batman
in a more sort of intimate Joker kind of
way yeah
um so yeah this this one yeah I thought
would be lower because at the time I was
like this feels like an adaptation maybe
not the adaptation but just the flavors
of like this Batman story with a strong
Catwoman element strong element of the
Rogues but still very much you know of
Gotham and all those things I just
thought it yeah it was like really
flavorful and nice [__] yeah I love that
uh I'm glad you got so much out of it I
always want people to feel all those
those details even if I don't uh my next
one is one you had a few ago the reign
of the Supermen uh for me this is up
there because it is continuing a story
that we have seen many times but we
haven't seen this part of it told a lot
we've seen a lot of the death of
Superman we haven't seen a lot of the
reign of the Superman now a lot of that
is because I grew up right as these were
getting really popular I remember the
death of Superman comic that black bag
that like sold out every everywhere I
remember reading the reign of Superman
and being like what's gonna happen so I
have a lot of like Nostalgia and emotion
can like tied to this era in comic books
I remember my uncle had all these comics
and I had a Spider-Man and X-Men because
I was collecting at the time so I'd be
able to read his DC books and these were
the some of the ones that I was like oh
my God I love DC so uh there's a lot of
love tied into that and I really think
they did a good job making us hate
certain characters love certain
characters I definitely was like oh
Henshaw I actually felt more animosity
towards him here than in the comics
which is impressive so it's one of those
things where if it improved upon the
comics it's going to be pretty high for
me and I really liked watching with John
because I knew every twist and turn and
he didn't so I got to kind of relive it
so I got to have the experience of being
like Oh wait I'm 10 again because I'm
watching someone like oh and in a new
medium it went from being like Flip Flip
Flip end of the month Flip Flip Flip to
someone being like I know
those are some of my favorite moments
right throughout this whole journey
because I could be like I love being
shocked and then being like I know this
the whole time yeah why did you say that
twist um so yeah I got to enjoy that uh
a new so that random Superman experience
is gonna make it higher both by
Nostalgia it's it's past present and
future improvements because I got to
live it again
so that's the man like part of me was
like I should put the heart like well
when you when you were like that's that
low I was like really like but that's
the thing because to me yeah like again
to me is is marginal and that's the
thing is is this is fun to me I like a
ranking where you could really argue it
and again where your opinion could be
drastically different day to day and I
love the Lex and Superboy stuff in that
movie like I've got seven movies tied
for second effectively because they're
all four star that's you know what
that's this list it's like seven times
per second five is like five movies yeah
there's one four and a half I have like
a bottle for a bunch of number fives and
then like a top five yeah so like it's
not bad it's just lower than yeah and
that's day by day yeah so that's where
today that falls at seven yeah and and I
do think that that uh reign of the
Superman
I don't know retroactively move it up
the list because it does really nicely
starting with all this chaos and then
tuning that into one it opens with so
many twists and the movie is a whopping
like 80 minutes it's 87 minutes and it
does like three hours of the
storytelling so that's the thing is both
times I watching it in full and then
watching back the reaction and stuff
both times I started out being like this
is wow this is a lot and then and then
as it goes I'm like they're doing a lot
this is cooking man and then by the end
you're like yeah like yeah and it is a
much better that's the thing is I wanted
to put more things between it and Death
of Superman just because it is a much
better part two than part one is which
is also impressive yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so yeah it's high up for me it's a
it's a confident great I will be in here
commenting on myself you know ranting at
me but maybe it should be higher yeah
leave a like if you would have ranked
reign of the Superman higher than me
closer there we go we just got two more
um
at least 600 66 before we're done here
oh I like that you know that ties into
my next movie pretty well what's your
number six
my 666 movie all right my number six is
Justice League
dark ah apocalypse War oh justice league
dark apocalypse war is my number what
six six okay good you're the number I
got you just like dark 666 it's
appropriate this was a hard one to rank
too and it's the most obviously fresh in
our minds from this continuity um but I
yeah this was one that I
I feel like a big culminative crossover
event you know climax can be a lot and a
lot to cram into not very much time yeah
and I feel like this there's just
something special about Constantine man
like this did really nicely I think to
pay off all the apocalypse and dark side
stuff that we had been building over
time uh you get all the sort of you know
heart
dropping you know nastiness of the
brainwashed Batman and the desperate
Superman you really feel like the end
times have come and gone and like we are
on this last ditched doomed mission to
just maybe scrape a chance at resetting
everything and maybe coming out a little
better than we did this time I felt all
those Stakes uh and yeah you do get like
this massive crossover as a result but I
thought it made for a lot of great uh
you know Justice League moments and yeah
you are separated from I mean you have
Clark Superman but he's depowered so
you're separated from a lot of the
things that bring you comfort in these
movies yeah and uh then having
Constantine really kind of have to step
up as the lead and having these dynamics
of his trauma regarding zatana and that
ultimate like tie around where it's like
Batman planned this lovely new love that
we would need you if [__] hit the fan
and so he knew to have zatana make you
run like there was just such a them was
such a beautiful piece and I saw it's
funny I saw somebody over there being
like you ranked War lower than
apocalypse were but to me like
apocalypse War managed to bring you all
that yeah foreboding and nastiness and
you feel the toll that all this is taken
however uh I feel like it it manages to
balance out like a a an appropriately
Hefty and dour finale but that also has
a certain amount of Triumph and then
when everything resets again it is kind
of a beautiful Coda to all of this in a
way to yeah pay off that first chapter
of Flashpoint you know I love that I I
have it higher but I love that I mean I
haven't said it yet and Tony Todd dark
side like always uh someone said in
Kingdom Come they have a kid I think
they mean one Roman and Superman yeah I
don't remember that I loved kingdom come
but I haven't read it since it wasn't
coming out I think I was like nine so uh
I love me some kingdom come from memory
but I had forgotten that element so I
apologize and apparently that is true
I'm trusting uh someone in the chat uh
and uh mabanga says that they have a kid
so I trust them uh and O'Mara does not
get enough respect of Superman uh it's
very good Batman I think he did a
terrific job agreed agreed uh I'm gonna
go with my number six also being 666
appropriate I got one where a guy
we've been here an hour [__] the city
uh I got Constantine city of demons I
love this movie this was the one that
had me just like I believe in animation
yes I believe that some medium serves
some stories better than others I've
always said the medium of Animation is
going to serve in some stories I I said
it earlier in this I said there are
things an image that would serve
animation better than live action I've
always said the medium is so important
to look at what you're making I think
the story they told in Civil War the
movie serves the movie Medium better
than the comic medium and I think the
comic medium told that story better the
mediums are important this movie is the
medium using R-rated animation I love
the magic I love the character I love
the voice performances I love the fact
that I I live in LA and I'm walking
around L.A thinking of Constantine
[__] my city I love that it affected
my day-to-day I love the experience of
what this town is is reflected in that
there are highs in this town there are
lows in this town this whole town is
reflected as well as the DC Universe so
it Blended the mediums of my life it
Blended my reality with my comic reality
and it did it all while telling a really
beautiful story that makes you feel for
Constantine that makes you suffer that
makes you understand that Constantine is
always suffering he always loses there's
always a cost I love the love of this
movie like this this is a love letter to
the character of Constantine who doesn't
get the credit he deserves John
Constantine is one of the best comic
characters of all time and this movie
knew it and loved it and it's really
hard not to put it higher I adored this
film here's here I hear you comfy 4.
very good it might be on my list I I
hope it could be I can only imagine it's
higher spoiler alert you never know it
might be it might be on the list
all right this is a hard list it was a
hard list to make absolutely is it one
more me and then we do more Super chats
did you do your six yet yes yeah yeah
you started remember his Apocalypse at
this time you pivot so yeah you got one
more and then we go to Super Chat all
right my number five break in the top
five right yeah okay my number five is
one obviously you have talked about it
okay
um but yeah this was one that really uh
just made a certain relationship sing it
did something for each of its characters
and that would be Batman
versus Robin there it is uh this was a
terrific story and this one was one that
really like I liked the intro to Damien
and Son of Batman and that was you know
my real first taste of Damien Wayne as
Robin as Bruce's all that stuff and I
knew that at the time you know yeah
Damien might not be everyone's favorite
Robin this movie really endeared me to
him to their relationship I think
they've done a really nice job across
all of the Damien Centric stories in
growing that character and bringing him
gradually out of this shell making him
authentic to where you met him but also
very much different than where you met
him and this movie is crucial to that
growth uh this gave us Weird Al as the
doll maker it did one of the most
satisfying like random cameos and yeah I
just love that it's a battle for
Damien's soul but it's also got to do
with the court of owls it's going deep
within the sort of conspiracies that
have built Gotham the shadowy
machinations that his parents may have
been involved with and uh and yeah it's
a great look at Bruce's character and
there's some great like sort of you know
nightmarish interludes kind of uh poking
and prodding at his psyche
um the the Samantha twist is like pretty
obvious that she's gonna be you know the
court and now one of the reasons it was
lower for me yeah like that's the one
major thing I would say like but also
like I I really liked Jeremy sisto's
talent and I really liked having these
dueling mentors and having uh Damien
really have to choose between one and
really come for himself to the ideology
of Justice not Vengeance and that so
reflects his relationship with his mom
and dad and that reflects Russia like
there's so much in it yeah it's terrific
it's like thinking about it there are
other installments that maybe come to
mind first that are maybe a little bit
flashier but this one felt like I was
reading a Batman graphic novel this one
felt like yeah I was getting a really
nice dive on both Bruce and Damien it's
developing both of their characters and
it's a little less Son of Batman has
that thing where Damien's like I want to
do things my way I know know what I'm
doing in Batman's like damn it Damien
you're a pain in my ass you need to
learn how to friggin be it's really a
father-son story like truly son about it
yeah and this one has that but you get
the benefit of actually getting to grow
beyond that initial point in a really
effective way so yeah I thought this was
terrific and that's why it's my number
fifth all right my number FIB is the
power of John Constantine mixed with the
Justice League themselves this is
justice league dark I adored this
because not only did it give my boy John
Constantine love which I just gave some
love number six but it included the
Justice League in a way that didn't
undercut either set of them I was so
impressed with how much this juggled
this truly felt like a team thing this
truly felt like all of the pieces were
served I love that Constantine kind of
led the Justice League here I love that
Batman kinda had to like be like well
sometimes I'm wrong not so directly but
I love how much uh you know Batman hates
magic I love how much they have to use
the occult here I love how much
everyone's out of their element accept
the magic users I love how they play
around with all the different characters
in a way that teaches you about them but
also gives you time to like uh engage in
their comic storyline and I think this
is the best use of Zatanna I think they
really gave Zatanna the Justice dark she
deserves I really really think league
dark uh I really think this is I love
Zatanna and if I was gonna say like hey
if you don't love the medium of comics
there's this character Zatanna I love I
would probably give them this like I
feel like this is how you show what
zatana her power set is how you show
Constantine in a team Dynamic it's a
little bit more approachable than
Constantine city of demons and that's
why like I think it's it's slightly
higher for approachability and re-watch
ability I think that if it was just
about like an experience I maybe was
more Palm sweaty in city of demons but I
think that justice league dark edges it
out just because it does Batman Justice
Constantine Justice a ton of Justice
like the justice league dark all get
that Just Desserts and and uh I don't
know it's damn near perfect like I don't
have anything that I like have I don't
have a negative that's why it's top five
like it's just so good a hard degree big
big big big I could have made my list
coin I you know I hope I just never to
hear about how and why it did just never
know I feel like that's to come it could
be I don't want to tease anybody too
much to get their hopes up but it could
be should we hop back in I think we
should see how the people are doing
leave a like for Zatanna by the way I
feel if you love Zatanna we need
Zatanna in the live actions on the
animated space we need more zatana in
every space I agree I agree and armas I
was ooh I'm I could see that yeah yeah
she just has that little twinkle in her
eye that feels like she knows magic she
does like already like like even without
her being cast but I see when I see
Under Armor I bet she knows magic like
just day to day as you do all right what
do we got what do we got all righty
let's hop back up
and thank you again thank you guys for
this is a bit different of a structure
than our normal you know movie news live
stream or spoiler talk live stream so
thank you guys for fueling the convo and
uh and yeah keep your uh thoughts and
opinions coming feel free to leave your
own versions of the rank yeah like if
you like this four to four hit that like
if you have your own Vision hit that
like also I want to hear I want to hear
your your lists absolute vodka all right
who did we leave off at oh we got a good
amount to get through all right here we
go
um
eyes thank you so much for joining in
and uh oh hey let's uh let's uh
there you go that's what I wanted
I think this series thank you doe Eyes
by the way thank you for contributing to
the Super Chat uh we're keeping them
open for the time being we'll probably
close them down in the next 20 or so
minutes
um but keep them going while you can uh
I think this series might be my favorite
thing on the channel right now can't
wait for more thank you so much doe eyes
let me get you there on the screen thank
you thank you thank you that really that
means a lot again I I'm not being you
know I'm not just blowing smoke when I
say that uh I'm extremely grateful for
this experience for you you know been
feeding gung-ho to do this every week
strap it in this has been a real treat
and a privilege I've done a lot of
series on the YouTubes and this is
amongst my favorite ever and and we
listed a few times why but it's also
like one I'm really glad we get to
continue with out of this universe I'm
glad there's so many is what I'm saying
and if this does well maybe we'll rank
the all of them at the very end which
would be like a six hour stream let's be
honest and that means sending those
lights if you want more rankings also uh
if this whole series does well mayhaps
Marvel because I had there's some stuff
I haven't seen over there oh yeah they
gotta have some good films in their
repertoire but uh thank you so much doe
eyes Fear and Loathing in general I like
that very very first name I'm just
clapping for your name it's for your
name
yes like Hunter would have liked etragon
yeah they would have gotten along I
think so too Gunn has said actors are
gonna uh pay themselves uh play
themselves ah actors are gonna do their
own pairs
over there yeah that one letter changes
a lot of that yeah Gunnison said his
actors are gonna play themselves across
media uh movie these games animated Etc
do you see this as a pro or a con I see
it as a pro uh I think it's something
that is definitely gonna have to we're
gonna have to wait and see just how much
consistency they can ring and the thing
is that this hinges on all of these
being successful to some degree
um but I like it I mean it's it's
unprecedented at the moment I feel like
to do video games animated shows and
movies and live action movies and have a
likeness of casts I mean even the MCU
right now doesn't completely have that
so that's a cool opportunity and I think
it could work I do think they're going
to be in their contracts from the jump
as opposed to Marvel that had to like
figure it out as they went along because
remember this in 2008 there weren't
shared universes so Marvel had to invent
a thing and then play catch up whereas
DC gets to go look what's working
and I feel like James Gunn also has a
lot of experience with shared universes
which again didn't exist so I think
there's a strength in doing it second uh
you know we've had other things do it
since but doing it to the scale second I
do think they're going to have more
scheduling ability because it's built in
because if you sign up for something for
a 10-year plan and you know you've got
this amount of time when you book other
things you're probably going to schedule
for it so I think this is a really
unique opportunity and I'm I'm excited
to see how it does absolutely same here
do you guys like that idea I mean I I
feel like generally people are pretty
excited but leave your thoughts below
leave a like for voice actors and live
actors across all media and uh Christian
unpronounceable oh we get to use a
hitherto unused sound effects he's dead
and I accept the Super Chat yes one of
the best lines real good work he's dead
and I accept the risks I love that and
the Super Chat uh Christian
unpronounceable thank you so much for
chiming in and yes he says I will
support a great channel that cares about
its employees and viewers love you guys
appreciate that very much appreciate
that we are we are very well taken care
of here we are very privileged and
blessed to be in the position that we
are in even in these strange and
uncertain times and uh and yeah
turbulent times thank you to Greg for
letting us both partake in this in this
mad you know kind of magical operation
that he's built yeah it's a it's a
really unique thing to be able to talk
about what you love for a living and uh
it is a tricky time for all of us uh
making what we love and talking about
what we love so it's uh it's very good
to have a seat and I much appreciate it
absolutely
612 concurrents that's my birthday
number that's good let's get to 612
likes from my recently past birthdays
that's all I want is a belated birthday
present of likes I got to be the person
that's saying happy birthday to John
first fun fact saw him the night before
and I was like I'm gonna call it I'm
gonna shoot my shot immediately I was
like I know what's coming honored koi I
was like it's 10 pm that's close enough
Liam hey I'll take it do you remember
that I was like it's like almost it's
1am in the east coast that means it's
somewhere it's your birthday and the way
I behave around birthdays is usually the
opposite is usually people being like a
week later like was it in your birthday
hey happy birthday you know did you hide
your birthday
I'm just not like the best at being like
guys
it's my birthday like come look at me
and I don't begrudge anybody who died I
wish I was that guy my birthday is
September 15th September you'll know the
first of the month of my birthday that's
in the middle you'll know I'm excited I
do well you mean you came to my last one
I can we had a we had a sunrise
that was a that was a request happy
birthday we birthday hard on my last
birthday
yeah I'm glad we bonded count on it
again that was a bonding experience and
I will
Liam can't wait for you oh oh wait wait
wait we can't proceed hold on a second
why did you said that can't wait sorry
that's that's not really a quote from
these movies but it is one of like the
most it's reliable us going through this
it's just as reliable as cars yeah it is
all right that's again if James Gunn
doesn't start out with a car chase on a
city street I will be very disappointed
Liam thank you for chiming in and uh
can't wait for you to watch the tomorrow
verse that is another pocket of this DC
animated goodness that I think I think I
think I think has at least a few
installments in it so it might be easier
to rank if it's less than 10. all righty
and uh yeah should we do one more yeah
well this ties into our last one oh yeah
so we should definitely include that one
all right Fear and Loathing in general
not vengeance
thank you so much oh and and yeah that's
for correcting that which is funny play
themselves a thousand parts are my type
but wouldn't want to look like an Ask
code I assume that was on purpose which
I also respect I hope it wasn't I like
the idea it's like I spelled it wrong
too late it's already sent it's already
out there you look like a double [__]
Fear and Loathing and generally
appreciated for your correction and we
got you all right all right all right
top four let's do the top four Final
Countdown yeah and then we'll uh get to
the we'll do the top four and then we
will open it up to the last of the super
chats we're nearing we're getting to the
point where we will have to wrap up
before too long so uh so get them in
while you can but koi what do you got
for us bud what's your number four or is
it me on number four You're Number Four
I am on number four well then John get
with the program all right what do we do
last oh here we go this is a fun one I'm
very curious because I know we have yet
to get to this for you uh
interesting okay there's still a couple
things left on this list we haven't
gotten to my one that I was like biggest
Gap either
that's true oh she's in my top four my
number four is a Justice League title
again
but it's also a crossover title and it
is Justice League versus Teen Titans oh
yes I'm number four is just
hold on where is it
there we go align the knot I think like
seven or eight of them have been the
same yeah they're a couple that are
desperate but for the most part all
right well then hey let's uh let's
teamwork what do we both think of
Justice League versus Teen Titans this
was this was such a delight and this had
a what I appreciated about this I think
the most was that it had this beautiful
influx of youthful energy that really
felt like uniquely
akin to teens without it feeling we
talked about this in the review I think
there's often a binary in in superhero
media especially where it's either like
really Kitty or for adults and I think
this really nicely occupies the middle
space world like yeah it's geared and
and in the voice of teens people coming
of age but also uh it's got all the
other things that you want it's got some
romance but it's got a really cool and
hellish kind of sci-fi horror
actionscape about it and yeah just the
character relationships the purpose it
serves for Damien's growth and the
introduction of characters like Blue
Beetle and Beast Boy and Raven
especially the dynamic having you know
like Uncle Nightwing and Starfire and
Uncle cyborg too like yeah there's just
so many charming and wonderful aspects
of that I don't want to hog all the
talking no no I totally agree with
everything you said and and we'll join
that with saying uh I love that it feels
like two different writers doing like a
mashup the young and adult uh themes are
both like you feel the Teen Titans
written young and you feel that's
written all but it doesn't feel like
they don't mesh it feels like the
universe is that well fleshed out it
feels like you found a university you
could have an all-ages thing but it
doesn't feel like it sacrifices either I
feel like both teams got there like do I
also feel like we actually got to see
some real dynamics between characters we
wouldn't normally get to see I think a
lot of people forget how the reason the
Avengers was so exciting is we'd never
seen that happen before we'd never see
some of these characters interact and a
lot of the fun of the Marvel film
universe is being like Oh my God what
would it be like a blah blah blah blah
blah blah and this felt like that to me
it felt like what would happen if they
and it was so cool it felt like a comic
it felt like when you're a kid in the
sandbox and you got all these toys and
you're like bet they'd talk like this
and like it worked so I love that the
reason they fought was due uh I love
that the reason they solved the problem
felt Justified I love that everything
didn't feel like it was just a a
McGuffin or a deus ex machina of like
why it's happening this movie
exceptional yeah absolutely and it it
manages to feel like you're reading a
Teen Titans book that still serves the
Justice League for why they're there and
the issues that are just listening that
feature yeah yeah and it makes sense why
they're fighting the power scale is well
attuned yeah because it could easily go
wrong in a movie like this yeah this was
just a real sort of surprise Joy yeah
yeah I agree didn't know what to expect
this was my first exposure really to
Teen Titans as a concept and uh and yeah
I think it's real Top Notch this was
definitely my biggest like wow this is
incredible and I'm surprised because I I
expected a lot out of Constantine I
didn't expect it that much but I didn't
expect a lot of Justice League versus
Teen Titans because I was like how are
they gonna make all those characters
work yeah five minutes like you God damn
right and we got to spend actual time
with them having fun which is I think
underrated I agree yeah fun like let
side scenes happen let like let the
scene at the farmhouse in Avengers Age
of Ultron happen let the bar scene like
you gotta let these characters breathe
absolute vodka well let's move on number
three here we go oh
oh koi oh we're getting close man what
we got my number three you've talked
about okay uh and I think we share a lot
of similar opinions on it okay
it is Constantine city of demons oh it's
good Constantine city of demons is to me
is the most sort of
unique in a way it's in its own unique
Lane and I appreciate that it certainly
has the things that you want out of a
comic book story that are maybe aimed at
a you know teenage audience or whatever
I feel like that's often you know sort
of part of your audience but this one
felt the most sort of committed to like
no we're gonna make this like an adult
animated movie with a very distinct
sense of Aura I loved using Los Angeles
and the dark shadow side of Los Angeles
as you said the personification of the
spirit of the city I think their takes
on you know demons and demonic figures
as like icky hell business folks works
better than I see it in a lot of other
media in this and yeah Constantine
yeah sure uh Constantine throughout this
journey is is just such a captivating
character and I thought this nicely
brought us a story that is very personal
to him to his past and backstory but
that also just feels huge and you know
like you're a wash in this magical realm
and this hellish realm and uh yeah it's
just it's punk rock and it's metal and
it's dank and moist and gooey and carnal
and demonic and dreary in a good way I
like the Aztec god stuff
um and you know little demon
constantines and everything
like the the resolve the tragedy of like
fixing the problem but at the cost of
everyone having to go their separate
ways the wiser I thought I had a great
pace and a great tone and just a great
sort of graceful sense of air about it
despite how you know kind of harsh and
hellish some of it is like this this was
operating on a different plane and to me
it was a breath of fresh albeit very you
know accurate acrid air yeah definitely
this was very gripping it does squelch
wetly it does the squelch is intense so
squelchy the squelch intensifies all
right number three in our most different
we have finally arrived we have arrived
Wonder Woman Bloodlines you remember
when this ended I was like they figured
it out they they wrote Wonder Woman and
I was like gobsmacked because this is
the Universe I think got Wonder Woman
the most wrong
and then the most right yes and I think
improving on a character might be harder
than just doing a character right yes I
the reason that Constantine is number
six and five is because they knew
exactly how to write him and that's why
he's so high up he's in the top 30s like
he's up there but the reason the Wonder
Woman's movie is number three is because
they got her so wrong and then they
slowly rebuilt my girl yeah and by the
time they fixed her I think that's
harder to do because they didn't they
didn't negate what they'd already built
they made it somehow so the stuff they
messed up they acknowledged they owned
they repaired their own problems and
they made her good and I think that in
an age of
um getting rid of Canon retconning
Madness like an age of like oh that
never happened or an age of like well
it's broken there's no solving it it was
beautiful to see a character get the
writing that went hey we're gonna
acknowledge that but we're gonna improve
upon it and they did that with Superman
and they did it with one Roman and I
really think this Wonder Woman movie
knows how good one Roman is I think
think it had a great villain for her I
think it really showed why the character
is important what she represents who she
stands for Wonder Woman's like Superman
she's aspirational she's not supposed to
be someone you're like oh yeah my buddy
Jim like you need to be like I love what
we could be I could never reach these
Heights but I believe in them and she's
not like stupid humans I'ma fight and
work for the president like some
iterations but she's like I want these
people to be as good as they can be why
can't I do more and they found it
finally so uh my number three is a bias
because I love Wonder Woman but I really
really think they found my girl and uh
Bloodlines I loved 100 man I agree and
then it yeah like I think it makes sense
because you have all that experience my
connection yeah but even I could tell
watching that movie even I could tell I
was like oh yeah this is cooking in a
whole other way and this feels this
feels spiritually correct much like uh
Constantine if they want to know about
Constantine I'd show them city of demons
if they can hang yeah Wonder Woman Like
I would say even maybe over the one
world first film because of what the
third act did I love the first Wonder
Woman movie but if someone wants to know
who one Robin is I might show them this
first sure it's that good those are
Constantine City demons and Wonder Woman
Bloodlines two of our lesser viewed but
two of them two of the best installments
so Shenanigans give those vids some love
although if you're here chances are you
already have and we appreciate you very
we will leave a like on your existence
for that
um all right we're in the top two I
think we have the same top one I think
we do I think we do let's see now's the
moment of truth of Truth and and I have
a sneaking suspicion that we might be
down for one last divert because my
number two
is Justice League
the flashpoint Paradox and hear me out
shock Hoy hear me out I guess we just do
two in one at the same time we must I
see here's the thing Flashpoint is
fantastic like this was one that blew me
away you know I'd heard so much over
time Flashpoint it's it's one of the
iconic story lines it's the Multiverse
you know one of the definitive sort of
multiversal uh uh Shenanigans sagas and
I thought this yeah what what can you
say that hasn't been said it's so
gracefully and beautifully centers
around this conflict for Barry Allen but
also you know becomes this whole Justice
League encompassing scenario I love
getting onto that alternate timeline and
the the the you know having this
alternate Batman who is like the sort of
worst case version of Batman but who's
not Beyond saving and then I'll never
forget moments like I mean the Martha
Wayne Joker is one of the absolute
Pinnacle moments of like shock
that might be my like number one moment
yeah like this was this this is like a a
hair's word like like this was it's so
good it manages yeah the flash and zoom
stuff really well
um the conflict of everything with his
mom his you know back and forth with
Batman you know it's like we've seen the
The Flash 2023 live action movie yeah
um which had its charms but that was one
of those movies where I was watching and
I'm like yeah this is like a version of
this story but it's not necessarily like
the version whereas I'm like I'm
watching this and I'm like I'm 100
Locked In yeah and this feels like it's
a definitive tumultuous version of this
classic story and yeah people have said
like it's really faithful to the book
and it's one of those movies where even
if I haven't read it I can tell like
yeah this feels very uh proportionate
conscientious it's got good character
beats while also balancing all this
chaos yeah yeah like I couldn't say
enough about honestly all right my
number two because we do diverge uh and
remember we'll get streamlabs next so
get those in if you want us to grab them
so we only got about 40 minutes left but
uh
it was way lower on your list I don't
know if you kept track but I have not
yet talked about justice league dark
apocalypse war that is the truth that is
my number two justice league dark
apocalypse War this did something
I didn't think was possible no I've
always said you cannot do this many
characters and this many moving Parts in
a single movie much less a 90 minute
movie and it did this movie accomplished
it ended a franchise it did it in a way
that was like honoring everything that
came before it its action was so well
developed it was so many moving Parts it
was so many storylines clashing into
each other but it didn't feel
overstuffed this movie is like a four
hour movie in 90 minutes and at no point
does it feel too much at no point did I
feel like it sacrificed what it had to
do with cyborg which frankly like my God
does talking about underserved
characters and movies it didn't
sacrifice who Batman was even though I
was like don't do that to Batman I'm
like that makes sense and to sacrifice
what Superman had to go through it
didn't sacrifice even when they made
Wonder Woman uh you know an element of
dark side when she came back it felt
like oh that's why it had to happen
because you had to have that moment
every single beat every beat the furies
all were like this has to be what it is
and I hate love it there's so many
moments in this where you're like are
they gonna get out of this and since it
was the end of a franchise there were
like two beats where I was like are they
just gonna end it really dark like I was
like does Darkseid win and I never get
to feel that because I know the comics
and I know that you know these
live-action movies are never gonna do
that so it actually had steaks because I
was like yo what if they do this and
dark side wins what if they like and and
that's how good it was to me because it
just threw me into a crazy like
tumultuous moment of like oh okay
they're going there so like for me
justice league dark apocalypse war is a
really long title that deserves its run
time uh and and yeah it so many
characters got Justice I agree loved it
wholehearted number three wholeheartedly
what what's your number one my number
was see this I lost track at some point
this is ultimately how this list shook
out because the flashpoint I feel like
for all intents and purposes like is the
answer so I did this in sort of like
yeah I agree but also my heart my taste
sure brings this one movie just a little
further past the line it is Justice I
did keep track Justice League revisiting
that like like a minute into the video I
was like ah this movie's so freaky and
the thing is this is like the perfect
balance for me where it's like you're
getting to know this other side of this
universe you're getting into the magical
the mystical the hellish and in this
world I really do adore that
part of it that that region because it
just feels so transportive so vivid and
distinct it feels like a holy other
place but that is absolutely a part of
the fabric of this universe and I
thought this movie in particular did a
nice job of splitting the difference of
being a Constantine movie essentially
and incorporating the Justice League but
also not again getting too Awash in you
know like a million different characters
like it's it's busy it's got a lot of
people but I love that what you
ultimately get is a Justice League
scenario insofar as you have Batman and
a group of people with a bunch of sort
of odd and random powers and then you're
sort of watching is yeah Batman is
technically our eye line for you know
the Justice League and yet Constantine
is really the one leading the show sure
um dead man like I absolutely love that
character and I love the way he comes
back for uh things with Nightwing in
certain uh installments and also leave a
like for Nightwing because we haven't
talked about it much but like he
throughout this entire series
um but yeah justice league dark just has
the perfect blend of horror stuff
mysticism but also the superhero aspects
I love him and Constantine going back
and forth about the pea shooter and then
coming in handy and all that yeah
Zatanna like you said is really gets a
chance to shine and even uh even the
villain uh Destiny like you know I
thought even though he's not like the
most fleshed out villain uh I thought
his presence and his just sort of heavy
metal demonic quality and the way you
see that in the etragon flashback with
blood like there's so many facets and
details and characters and story lines
that are all so rich and have such an
aura and combine I think in a perfect
synthesis what I love about the
superhero the classic superhero side of
these stories and the potential for
horror and fantasy in these totally
agree and I don't like everything you
just said I totally completely agree
with him actually into that film I
totally like and I think that's the
difference between being
seeing a new genre shown in animation
which is what I got out of it versus my
comic book love which is why my number
one yeah is Flashpoint uh okay and my
real number one is Batman versus Team
Ninja Turtles but that's another video
my number one in the DC Animated
Universe I see you chatting you're also
correct uh is Flashpoint because I think
Flashpoint might have hit me harder than
the comic and Flashpoint is one of the
hardest hitting Comics I've ever
experienced it goes hard so for me this
is the the four and a half Star movie on
the list and there's there's I think
four four and a half star films now
total in all of the DC Animated Universe
I've given it to a few other ones which
we're gonna rank in the DC Au whenever
we get to them because there's a lot of
them but um I've given it to like a
certain Frank Miller movie a certain uh
yeah so there are ones but for me
Flashpoint
I think emotionally grips me a little
bit more than the comic because I really
really hated yellow flash reverse flash
made me so angry and I love the
portrayal I really felt for Barry losing
his mom I really felt that like the else
worlds were actually the best I've seen
them served it felt like another world
it felt like they really captured the
element of like unnerving unreality and
that's hard to do an animation when
everything is not our reality like
everything because it's animated so to
serve that medium in a way that made it
feel like a different world was so
nicely done the voice performances were
great I think that's the one I'm the
most invested in emotionally and that's
why it's so high up and to be honest
um this I you guys know I had fun with
The Flash movie I really got a lot out
of The Flash movie The Flash movie made
me like this even more and that's not
saying the flash movie's bad it's saying
it made me appreciate what the medium of
Animation gave me with Flashpoint it
gave me more over here so
um flashpoint was everything and uh I
got a lot out of it four and a half
stars and uh yeah it was me Barry like
like the memes that came out of it the
pop culture moments it's just so good to
me yeah so yeah it's good to meet you
that's my number two I'm just it's
almost if there's someone in the chat
inevitably I'm like remember my opinion
I'm not talking to you because we've
been on the same page when someone's in
the chat's gonna be like No Justice
League War is better because that was my
last one when I when I started ranking
these when I started the list I was like
well I'll just put Flashpoint at the top
you know to start you know and not not
in in any sort of dejective way I was
just like yeah and then you're like wait
I'm remembering Justin and then yeah and
then I was like I know jail dark is
going to be high and then when I
rewatched it I was like you almost moved
reign of Superman I think the only one I
might move with mine is
Constantine I think Constantine might be
my top five I think I might shift uh
justice league dark and Constantine up
together and then I might move uh
whatever my number four was I can't
think oh just like Teen Titans uh just
down to five yeah because I really like
the constant stuff really gets me it's
so great and stuff and unique yeah it's
it's not like the top six might all
change that's how good they all are yeah
so yeah very very much my jam uh let's
get some more Super chats and streamlabs
do that guys we did 16 in an hour and a
half I'm proud of us uh I was a little
worried about that that factor so I like
this four and four thing if we do more
of these rankings I like that system I
think I think grids are for good but
we're gonna get to each and every one of
your super chats and stream Labs uh
we'll keep that open for another uh like
10 minutes and then we're gonna we're
gonna turn that off because we gotta
wrap this bad boy out so you got 10
minutes to get your stream Lads and
super chats in let's get after them yes
indeedy all right let's do big Chuck
420 look out let me move this box here
so you can see your comment there a
little bit bitter all right big Chuck oh
hold on hold on hold on
all right we're gonna go with a
different one then because that one's
not working he's dead and I accept the
Super Chat yes Loved re-watching These
with y'all Flashpoint Paradox is my
favorite I rewatch it the most I love
the whole Flashpoint Universe in the
books as well how perfect time let's
expand yeah uh there's a lot of
elseworlds that kind of came out of
Flashpoint they've definitely given some
of those characters like full-on story
lines
um like I'm pretty sure Batman
um the Thomas Wayne Batman and Martha's
joker as their own miniseries like
they're stuff that like goes so there's
places to play so uh there's there's if
you like it there's more to dive into
and uh thanks Big Chuck we're on the
same page and John's got it at number
two so we all love it oh hey somebody oh
who said that in the chat uh somebody
said Son of Batman the glove official
has the best Nightwing suits on a Batman
oh I don't disagree I I also like yeah
there's a we could do an hour on each of
these like there's so many elements like
I think the animation in Batman hush
makes it like top tier there's certain
things that like sure Elevate or detract
but yeah I I did dig the Batman
Nightwing suit in Son of Batman
absolutely Dan V
900 super chats not vengeance I loved
your reactions but found most of the DC
AMU to be mediocre at best especially in
comparison to the DC animated series
Flashpoint if you're counting it is
number one for me then death of soups
hey Flashpoint is absolutely it's the
kickoff it's the first one but so we're
definitely counting that I mean fair I
think this is for me been more good than
not good I mean I feel like most of
these have given me that feeling of like
well they better to do a lot in an hour
and 20 minutes yeah
um so you know I don't fully share your
sentiment here but I could see where
you're coming from yeah I mean I
personally disagree clearly but uh at
the same time I haven't watched a lot of
the DC animated series or or I don't
know if that counts the other things
we're doing or is that TV I don't know
what that applies to but there are
certain aspects of the animated movie
Universe no there are certain animated
movies that tie into the DC animated
series
Batman and all and Justice League the
enemies he was honest okay got it yeah
those yeah those occupy a pocket of the
animated so many pockets Multiverse so
many pockets but that's a guy at least
we can agree on a couple good ones here
and I'm glad that you like death of
Superman a lot as well I feel like
that's an iconic storyline so you know
I'm grateful that people you know are
pleased with that yeah uh my name is
Matt
[Music]
lies
Super Chat
what Marvel Comics storyline would you
want to see made into an animated movie
koi uh
uh Sinister Six I feel like the Sinister
Six uh the closest we'll ever get is no
way home and I loved it but I definitely
feel like there's an opportunity to make
I've always wanted to write a Sinister
Six that is
um like the Ocean's Eleven movie I want
to make a heist movie where the the
leads are the villains of the Sinister
Six and Spider-Man's the bad guy uh I
always thought it'd be cool to have like
Sandman being like I just want to take
care of my daughter Rhino's just trying
to get the money together that suit
um you know like they're not like good
but they're not like just clearly
villains so I thought it'd be fun to do
an underdog villain Heist movie with
Spider-Man as the antagonist uh and I
feel like animation is the only way to
really do that uh I also think clone
saga movie would be dope uh I also think
they're dark Phoenix
um I'd love to see um some Cosmic X-Men
stuff I feel like X-Men really serves
animation with the mutant Powers
um that's just marvel but if we're
talking all Comics Saga absolute vodka
all right moving forward clipping along
got a couple more minutes will probably
close the super chats down in like five
minutes or so so keep on keeping on
appreciate all of you for sticking it
out with us on a Sunday morning leave
that like if we can get to 666 before
the stream is oh okay I like it yeah we
will do something fun and special we'll
do something for uh for your troubles
there uh Hey Fear and Loathing in
general super chess not vengeance
absolutely you know what's crazy koi
it's got a lot of A's I was talking to
Mabel the other day y'all know Mabel So
I says to Mabel I says wouldn't The
Flash have been a better film does this
continue this no I think it's oh there
it is oh it does it does indeed if it
were heavily but if it were heavily
budgeted animated film a la spider verse
uh same story beats but quality
animation thank God it's free to share
ideas right good old Mabel ah Mabel I
hope they will receive that knowledge
well Mabel's watching right now uh I
feel like Flashpoint did a darn good job
of making a quality animated film out of
it but I would also love to see I would
watch something in the vein of spider
verse yeah I would watch The Flash
averse version Oh and a heartbeat that
sounds amazing I mean because I think
yeah just the the potential of any
Universe you go to having a different
you know whole tone look aesthetic Vibe
you know medium it is being realized in
is a very fun Prospect totally agree
we'll see see how the new TMNT does with
that jittery sort of comic book style
very helpful yeah Dan V 900 he's dead
and I accept the Super Chat yes all
right flash point Paradox thank you for
contributing as well uh Flashpoint
Paradox was the final DC animated film
funded by WB Premiere before it shut
down the direct video budgets were then
slashed which is why the films look
cheaper post 2013. it is noticeable it
is fair I mean I feel like um
yeah I can kind of see it it's like a
splitting of the difference I feel like
I look back on like stuff like Batman
the Animated Series and I'm like yeah
that feels like animation man uh and
these movies I think do have a nice and
animation style some more than others
they're not always like you know all the
gorgeousness of the anime but I think
they do nicely to split the difference
between a comic book style animation and
and this universe in and of itself isn't
doing quite as much direct referencing
of you know aesthetic languages as like
something as like a year one was or Dark
Knight Returns sorry I was doing or you
know uh uh long Halloween sure
um that airs uh next Sunday
oh yeah there's there's there's new DC
AMU keep your eyes peeled maybe even as
soon as tomorrow maybe even keep your
eye out in the morning
um but yeah I mean it didn't seem like a
like a I wasn't sitting here going man
these movies are really going downhill
uh yeah there are certain ones I think
throughout though that still manage to
flourish despite that budget cut so for
me I feel like it certainly could be
worse yeah and I think that honestly you
know it's it can be noticeable but if
you stylistically work around it that I
I wasn't often distracted by a weakness
in animation I can I can acknowledge
that flashpoint was incredible but I
also wouldn't uh demerit a lot of the
other ones because animation is a is a
hell of a tricky medium and I think they
did their job serving the story absolute
vodka well all right thank you Dan V
Sean Payton hey coin John bars hold on
hold on
hold on he's dead and I accept the Super
Chat yes hey coin John recovering from
an oral surgery and this has brightened
up my day oh well I'm I'm glad we should
be of service absolutely uh question for
koi what character was misused uh in the
DC
EU or the D I'll I'll expand it or the
DC AMU if you have one and uh John and
Coy any plans to start the tomorrow
verse
um not 100 sure when and how the
tomorrow verse will factor in but it's
certainly on the table I feel like
there's certainly a chance that it'll
come
to pass I don't know if it'll exactly
become the kind of thing where you know
end up for dcamu we kind of we we went
linearly we diverted once in a while I
don't know if it'll be exactly as
consistent as that but I think we will
get into some of those films at some
point keep your eyes peeled yeah um but
yes any characters particularly misused
[Music]
okay if you consider the DC EU and
elseworld which I do they're all great I
think that Zack Snyder just sees the
characters differently than I uh and
that's okay because they're archetypal
characters that's the thing however if
you see it as the mainstream Universe I
don't particularly consider a Superman
that kills or Batman that uses guns to
be the characters so uh perhaps the two
out of three leads of it
um would be misused
um but that that's all on how you
perceive the character so I can't speak
to what's misused or used correctly
because the way the characters are
written is meant to be interpretive and
the way the characters are perceived is
going to be different for you than for
me so for me I love experiencing those
movies as an elseworld but if it was my
universe Batman wouldn't shoot people
and and Superman wouldn't uh breaking
next
I feel that anybody in the AMU
um the AMU the only one I felt like uh I
I didn't she was only in like the movies
a couple times but Zatanna like there
could have been more when she was in it
she was great but I definitely feel like
there could have been opportunities to
incorporate her more and a total lack of
detective chimp yeah I know he never
appeared I was thinking that I I was so
looking forward to he's the best the
character that's misused is detective
detective Jim because he's not in him
and they faked us out because there were
monkeys there were monkeys and there is
no justice league dark to me without
detective chimp who I love okay that's
see that's why that's my number one yeah
I see I see all right let's let's real
quick that might have changed everything
Flashpoint might not have had a chance
in the world without detective chimp but
since he never showed up that's the
pocket aces you put detective Chimp in
something a plus all right I use them
right all right let's jump back over to
the stream labs and in 60 seconds 60. I
am going to close out the super chats
for the day so you got a mo left if you
want to get that last one and you can
still send stickers if you'd like but
but yeah for questions 60 seconds we are
going to close that down but let's hop
over here and let's hop into the last of
the stream labs for the day it is
um boom let's see
we left off at 12 15 if that helps oh
that's that is good so a little bit
better we got 202 from Sony I believe so
yeah because we talked about the
breakfast joke yeah all right
let's do this thing then we got Sammy
boy let me make sure we can see you here
we go perfect Sammy boy and uh I got a
phone call why did you said that super
chat chat there you go two films I
really love thank you for joining in as
well uh two films I really love are on
top of my list All-Star Superman and
Superman versus the elite bit biased but
these movies are really show why
Superman is more than just a boring
overpowered superhero according to many
hope we get that lasso optimism in
Legacy uh yeah I really really uh look
forward to those experiences because I
think All-Star Superman the comic is one
of the best Superman stories period uh
Superman the elite if it's in that same
area I really really look forward to it
uh I think Superman can be perceived
that way I don't think when Rich and
well he is I think and poorly he
absolutely can be but I'm really excited
for uh some optimism and uh and as you
describe it lasso optimism uh yeah Ted
lasso is man that's the closest man I've
seen on TV in a while I and that's not
to disparage I just haven't watched
Superman and Lois but uh it's really
good to see that kind of optimism in a
show and and I'm excited to see that in
Superman again absolutely uh Sani we got
one more from you appreciate you chiming
in I like the casting of lantern Hawk
woman and Mr terrific I feel they are
the three really good choices because
while they are heroes I don't have the
Superman way uh they don't have the
Superman sense of being a hero guy is a
dick uh terrific is too logical and
hawkwoman can be ruthless so I am in
co-signed I I think that's a big part of
why those were the first ones announced
I think that does tie directly into what
they're planning to do I'm with you
absolutely well all right let's uh let's
refresh the stream Labs one more time
oh did you accept the ramifications I
need to yes understand that understand
the implications all right let's hop
back over one more time thank you again
guys for for contributing and for
keeping uh just our conversation fires
stoked and a light
um yeah dude this has been a real good
lovely old time and uh here we go what
do we got what do we got where do you
remember where we left uh let me see let
me see uh we did not get to crisis we
did not get to that one uh I think we
left off on uh Charities oh no we we
jumped ahead to finish his share ideas
yeah we got my name is Matt for sure so
scroll up from there we're above this
for sure yeah cool uh we did the crazy
with all the and then Flashpoint is a
final DC we talked about that covering
from our world series we talked about
that okay cool so so we are here I think
with Goldie Jones justice league dark oh
oh wait let's get you let's get shot
guys we're 29 likes from uh getting a
nice even 500. what did you said that
super chat chat dude let's get that last
few likes just as league dark is so far
you could do a straight adaptation I
agree and I I we were talking in that
first video uh Guillermo del Toro
wanting to do one and I so wish that he
had man I just dream of it often I think
that his character designs would be so
special Jim Leonard happy birthday on my
birthday we share a birthday I'm excited
about it absolutely oh oh Rhett Proctor
super chats not vengeance
go uh hey guys what oh wait let's let's
do it let's do you know let's kind of
bump up
lies the feelings Super Chat love etch
again throughout this uh hey guys what
do you think about Jensen Ackles playing
our DCU Batman he's on the fourth he's
on his fourth Robin and the dad of a 12
year old do you think it could work and
Jensen's Batman voice is really good I
would love to see a live-action uh
Jensen Batman portrayal uh yeah I think
he just has the voice he's got the look
he's got the vibe I think you know the
further we get from stuff like
Supernatural and the boys he certainly
helps I think that's the only issue for
me is he has like these very attached
bits of exposure
um but yeah I've loved the turns we've
heard from him in the animated realm and
would be overjoyed to have a Jensen
Ackles Batman personally all of what he
said plus uh he knows the fandom and I
love
love uh that he is such an interesting
element of Phantom and that he he takes
so much time he really cares like every
con he's out there in the front lines
and he really takes time with her he
cares about fandom itself and I think
whoever's gonna play Such my kind of
character for fandom should be willing
to put themselves and you don't have to
like I I know plenty of actors who don't
want to be you know at a con every
weekend and that's their rights like
it's your life you shouldn't have to do
something because you're obliged but if
you're gonna join a fandom like this I
love that he also is willing because
that's a huge part of it yeah absolutely
Dan v900 back in Action uh you love
Jon's use in crisis on Two Earths yeah
he is a main character in Justice League
the New Frontier which is a fast
fantastic film and feels cinematic still
my favorite Justice League film I'm
excited to get to check that out it
sounds great that's on the on the agenda
at some point it's common Two Earths was
great I really enjoyed that one too that
was really enjoyed it yeah
great
so much goodness like elseworlds flash
Point different kind of yeah timeline
wonky stories that was a word salad yeah
those are all true adjectives those were
things that are said super chats not
Vengeance Michael thank you so much hi
guys thoughts on the DC AMU skipping
Jason and Tim I personally don't mind
their absence but I found it odd to
completely omit their existence
um I don't think
I don't think these movies suffered for
me for not having those characters
especially because we did watch you know
under the Red Hood to kick this off but
uh yeah no uh Jason and Tim like I would
have been curious to see I think Tim
especially just because I feel like I
don't know that character as well as
most of the other Robins now and I feel
like that's the one where
you know Jason is tied to a very
specific story whereas you know uh Tim
would just be cool for me to see kind of
development his different Dynamic is I
know a lot of comic creators that's
their favorite Robin like a lot of comic
creators I know Tim is their favorite so
I would love to see a lot more people
get exposure to him that being said I'd
rather not have them in it than have
them in it and be underserved I'd rather
have it how it was than like shoehorn
the man and then just be like hi I'm
here for a second I'm Robin and leave so
personally uh I was okay with it in this
instance yeah yeah I feel you Dan V 900
back in Action thank you for holding it
down and for being so generous today
really do appreciate you and and you're
off you're you're here so often like it
really does mean a lot to have you with
us uh oh yeah there we go I gotta get
people's
get the names in here we are 10 likes
away from me yelling excited Hush The
Long Halloween with an incredibly
unbatman-like decision to end it and
Gotham by Gaslight all have a big change
and try to be too smart not great
interesting I like the Long Island quite
a bit I like the long Halloween too or
uh you know stay tuned we got we got
reactions to that on the way
um I'm curious about Gotham by Gaslight
and and mostly for these other you know
uh sort of outside the continuity ones
I've seen like little bits and pieces of
response but I haven't dug too deep
obviously because I want to preserve the
the surprise of the experience but but
yeah I mean I think that's also the
hazard of adapting a beloved plotline
especially apparently disappointing to
some yeah and hush yeah certainly is one
where I'm like yeah I can absolutely see
why you don't care for what they did
with that you know it's lower on my list
for a reason uh it's it's you know in
the middle or lower because of uh it's
gorgeous and I love that story but yeah
that did bother me overall I just it
also just slightly shifted remember
those two swapped because of that like
oh at least it's surprising but yeah I
agree absolutely uh raccoon shampoo back
in Action scroll down for you and uh
what he's dead and I accept the Super
Chat yes I saw that you did long
Halloween part one are you planning to
do the tomorrow verse in release order
after that not 100 sure we're probably
gonna my guess would be that we're gonna
be hopping around kind of going off-road
and stuff like that I think some
tomorrow verse movies certainly would be
potential for being a part of that
mixture I just don't know if it'll be as
dedicated of a run as this particular
continuity I think it's a smaller
continuity or there are less films to it
um but I think there's there's a strong
possibility that they will show up at
some point in this journey also there's
500 of you in here and if any of you
live in Southern California Comic-Con
Saturday 1pm come ask us these questions
in person absolutely come ask us every
one of your burning questions about the
see Animated World Jeff Carroll
hey you lovelies with guns initial DC
announcement about keeping connectivity
between TV film gaming and animation
which actor would you most like to see
in both live action and animation and
two of two is there anyone who's already
voiced an animation that you would like
back for Live Action not sure the
likelihood but if Wonder Woman is recast
Rosario Dawson is my pick and she's
voice Wonder Woman for several
animations very much enjoy her Wonder
Woman
um that's a great excellent question koi
you know I don't think I could love
Rosario Dawson more so if she's cast in
something it could be a librarian it
could be Wonder Woman it could be a book
from the library and I would be excited
because I I got a lot of love for that
woman as an actress and a person she's
very kind caring and geeky um
I am very excited about the connectivity
we talked about that a little earlier
um you know
Matt Ryan I think I think he of anyone I
would love to see
um get brought in as Constantine because
he just so good in the animation we've
seen uh yeah I'm gonna go man Ryan and
if not Matt Ryan I want to see a brand
new John's Constantine that's that good
get to do all of it uh and like someone
with a like an authentic accent I wanna
I want someone like Street British
um so yeah that those are my two
absolutely that's a good call I would
say maybe
uh Weird Al is the doll maker there it
is that's your big pull on the big
screen he wants it folks Tony Todd Dark
Side too it's a good one it's a real
good one don't disagree uh J
Bonifacio lovely name there that you got
uh let me see here hold on super chats
not vengeance quick sidebar have you
checked out my adventures with Superman
so good so far I have not but I've been
hearing people talk about it is that
that anime Superman show not a single
frame but well I've seen like Stills uh
but yeah I have not and I love Jack a
lot so I I will haven't James desio in
the chat says Daniel kaluya for
Constantine this is like Kobe Brown
that's a that's a that's a thick suggest
but I I kind of I'm chewing on it and I
I my just metal detector of the soul is
kind of fun at the top so five out of
three likes we did
[Music]
all right Mars eight Productions
he's dead and I accept the Super Chat
yes great to see you guys together on a
live stream thank you very much for
being here and for helping to make it
what it has been uh some of my favorite
reactions on the channel and same here
really appreciate that uh since Keanu is
aging out who would be your dream
casting for Constantine to lead the
magical side of the deal well well well
what timing you
um
much younger Jason Statham
Dan Stevens
man I don't know like I would kind of
mate like Dan Stevens might be too
profile now but yeah I could see him
being a good Constantine I want someone
that like looks like they smell sure I
want someone that's like super scummy
like would just you walk into a pub and
you're like maybe not here like I want
someone that makes you turn around
um
I don't know what's up my head that's
really hard if uh
man if like
if clean Crawford is British I love
clean Crawford sure um yeah I don't know
that's hard Matt Ryan for now all right
all right that's a great great question
I gotta I gotta think I want to honor it
with thinking on it more Mike Joseph
Quinn looks like he smells nice yeah I
mean smells bad I want someone that
looks like they smell like the the bad
side of the underside of a pub table not
someone that you're like man I want to
hug this guy Joseph Quinn's real
huggable huggable guy Mike Tavares yeah
lately I've been thinking Keegan Michael
Key would be a great Lex Luthor he looks
like the animated Lex I feel like he has
a real serious side to him
I think that would be cool maybe Joseph
gilgan for Constantine Joseph
he was um
he was in preacher
okay sure
oh interesting yeah yeah he's the the
the demon vampire's the vampire yeah I
mean he might be too old as well but
like man his energy is so like you're so
captivated by him while also being like
I don't know why I want to talk to you
like he's just got this Nest man yeah I
mean he's also my card but like he he's
something special yeah I don't know
maybe him all right all right cool cool
but uh sorry I was still on it but yeah
kicking Michael Key Lex Luthor I I think
it would be fun I think it would have
the obstacle would be having to
transcend like the Luther of it all love
the Luther the the anger translator uh I
feel like Keegan Michael Key can do
intensity and I'm so used to the comedic
aspect of him breaking that intensity
with comedy so it would just be about
getting over that hump yeah yeah I agree
uh I I could you know see it it's just
uh it's not my first instinct but I
could definitely see it I'd have no
problem with it I'd love to see him try
it out
absolutely
be an interesting piece because get
Jordan peel as I think some of the best
comedians are up I think some of the
best comedians are great dramatic actors
because they have to know timing in
certain elements that like yeah and uh
oh here we go shepherdin tolerant super
checks not Vengeance absolutely koi saw
the Twitter stuff thank you for joining
us here as well just know we all love
you and some of us following you aren't
those BS folks peace and love to all we
love you here I appreciate that uh
enough people were like ruined the real
rejects I had to be like let me go ahead
and kick back a little bit and then the
the ratio you showed me uh the ratio
showed me how wrong they were but you
know I I uh I've Loved this channel
forever so it was an honor to join it
and uh when I did I didn't want to ruin
it so when someone says something that
specifically F you I responded with my
own blend of Fu and then one on their
pages and they were like oh you're just
like boring or and or bad people so if
you're boring or bad you're kind of like
irrelevant to me and thus now they are
as well Boogie so thank you thank you
you aren't you you're very relevant and
I love you very much I appreciate it and
you know who else is neither boring bad
nor irrelevant is Frank DX we love frank
super chats not Vengeance can't decide
and thank you for being here can't
decide which one is my favorite flash
pointer apocalypse War by the way one of
you guys watching Barbie or Oppenheimer
uh Oppenheimer I think sometime this
week Barbie not sure yet
um and yeah I mean Flashpoint and
apocalypse War those are two very worthy
options for your uh favorite number one
uh I mean does my number one and two
personally yeah so and then I think
they're both in your top five yeah so
yeah very very sorry the apocalypse
might have been six but yeah it is real
close yeah so incredible incredible
experiences I totally totally agree
um and hopefully
within the next month I mean Comic Cons
around the corner yeah that's my main
focus I'm just trying to survive yeah uh
Dan V
900 what did you said that super chat
chat never forget that Constantine is
pronounced incorrectly everywhere except
the Sandman show it's supposed to be
like wine not teen sorry Alan Moore so
it's Constantine
what when where what's the where's the
uh and uh is it etymology for Words
where's where's the etymology
Constantine
Constantine I could definitely hear I
mean that is how it said in the same
head but like I felt like that was just
like Sandman has like its own aura so
like Sandman
is inherently more like Posh I never
yeah
uh Hey koi raccoon shampoo wants to know
can you recommend any Green Lantern
stories thank you for contributing uh
recently if you want to learn about Guy
Gardner there's a really fun turn in
human target a book I've recommended to
John a few times
um there is a good Jon Stewart story
called Green Lantern oh it's like a
quilt
um it's uh it's a story with like a
tapestry of different worlds colliding
and he has to help control all of them
uh you know what um my YouTube page I've
got uh what to read if you are excited
by the James got announcements from like
three months ago and Green Lantern is
one of them because when they announced
Green Lantern I gave some of my favorite
Green Lantern stories so they're in
there for sure that might help
um but yeah recently uh I I've not been
vibing with them as much there's some uh
there's a Green Lantern story with Liam
sharp art that was really intense
visually the story kind of wavered in
and out for me it's Grant Morrison so
it's very heady I love Grant Morrison
but the story did not always hit but
that's a that's a pretty solid recent
run with Hal Jordan
um I'm a Kyle Rainer guy so if you go
back to Green Lantern number one from
like 1994 or that's the era I really
love he's like everyone's least favorite
Lantern but he's my favorite so I'm a
Kyle Rainer guy so I'd go 90s Kyle
Rainer Green Lantern number one uh and
see if that's your thing Boogie go forth
Dan v900 thank you once again for
chiming in JL dark is great the only
reason the film got made was due to
Batman being put onto the team which the
creators discussed for fear of sales it
worked I think it absolutely worked and
it made for yeah a really fun Dynamic it
made for some good humor with Batman but
it also yeah is the novelty of seeing
him and Constantine co-lead a team of
magically inclined totally hellish
characters I love it so much totally
co-signed I I'm really glad they added I
mean it didn't feel shoehorned I'm glad
they did it no yeah it served Batman and
the rest of the actual Justice League in
their involvement as well as just yeah
all the Constantine they rewrote well uh
raccoon shampoo thank you for watching
generosity
lies the demons Super Chat just realize
that Peacemaker opens with him driving
home from the hospital and Suicide Squad
opens with them in the chopper slash
plane vehicles does James God already
know the real secret ingredient we've
already been we've already been treated
to it it's already right is now we're
two out of two which means even if the
next one doesn't we're still on an above
average so just like the DC AMU is above
average doing it we can still hope
because that's delightful tidbit thank
you raccoon shampoo we're gonna re-watch
those those eyes most certainly and Dan
V 900 back in Action as well this is our
final
acceptance
is that a sticker yeah it's a sticker
okay uh you have to watch the Wonder
Woman 2009 film Carrie Russell is Wonder
Woman Nathan Fillion is Steve Trevor and
Alfred merlina is Aries it's the best
Wonder Woman film star to finish the
third act and use of Aries perfection
we will have to watch that definitely
all right good to know appreciate that
I'm gonna screenshot there it is that's
a that's a saving it no idea I love that
whole cast good thing all right well
Kiana Chanel thank you so much for the
sticker
not Vengeance I love the little flying
oh wait no hold on
lives
Super Chat yes
oh good and uh peeve you can skip any
videos that I'm in don't worry what did
you do I don't know but you know it's
worth it but he's this close you'll find
other things he's this close thank you
for the series we love you Kiana thank
you for just holding it down for always
being lovely and supportive you are
super this is I mean you you got the
little capable headband you're you are
super and that's uh that's thematic
sticker appreciate you very much for
being here Carlos seals thank you for
the moment of silence
not Vengeance appreciate you being here
for chiming in and uh for making us feel
loved oh I see more now my apologize
there's more questions so I just saw a
space Carlos seals we're getting close
though we're getting down
lies defeat
Super Chat absolutely these animated
movies have made me love Damien Wayne I
agree how do you think he will translate
to live action though also koi are you
going to uh you are going to love
Superman in The Tomorrow verse I look
forward to loving Superman I love that
character uh let's see live action I do
think they are going to have lots of
source material where the character is
more beloved so I think they're gonna do
them well like I'm really not worried
about Damian Wayne Uh I know a lot of
people didn't love the character but I
really think especially with John
discovering him and re like learning
about him
um like I I this is a great Testament to
like people that don't have a lot of
exposure realizing how great the
character may be doing right so I'm not
worried yeah and then thank you I'm
excited for tomorrow I think it can be
tricky I think there is a scrappy do
hole you can follow too easily if you're
wrong yeah I feel like it is tricky in
that you gotta make him understandably
angsty and annoying in the right ways to
yeah to where those edges can be sanded
down and can become Charming rather than
just always annoying but yeah I think
it's a slippery slope but I think they
can do it with the right casting and I
think James Gunn has a good sense for
that side of things especially uh
raccoon shampoo back in Action thank you
so much
holding it down in the super chats here
long Halloween is part of the tomorrow
verse by the way that's good to know
we've already begun we've already begun
then keep an eye out this week uh part
one is coming at you and I believe
finally we have made it Heather gear uh
thank you so much for chiming in Heather
is uh is a dedicated super sexy reject
he's dead and I accept the Super Chat
and uh thanks for chiming in here as
well thanks for joining us on a Sunday I
started watching all these for the first
time with you guys and it's been so fun
to journey through with you Batman vs
TMNT was my fave much love uh can't say
enough about Batman versus love to hear
it I'm very excited to talk about that
one on some some other video but if you
want to see us talk about it on that
video you get in there and you watch
that also uh if you guys want to watch
us watch these in their entirety like
she did there is absolutely a journey
called patreon where you can watch them
from start to finish which she does with
us as well that you can and thank you
for for yeah for making our journey as
lovely as it has been so far because it
is largely through your guys uh you know
just enthusiasm and love that this
journey has been what it is yeah uh
Vincent Moore uh second to second to
second to last here super chats not
Vengeance hi John and Corey Corey I love
who oh dude you've got an alter ego uh I
love y'all reviews on the DC animated
movies the new ones I like are Green
Lantern beware of my power and battle of
the super Suns I haven't even heard
those so I'm very excited not bad
and thank you for appreciating the
reviews as well I feel like yeah do not
stick around for that stuff so uh that
means a lot thank you put our heart into
them thank you so fun to discuss and
such a treat and a joy to talk about uh
so yeah I really really really
appreciate that you appreciate those as
well uh raccoon shampoo holding it down
all day
thank you for being here uh and yes
goodbye to you
final a written chat have a lovely end
to your day and uh finally Chris Wham
off to end us off he's dead and I accept
the Super Chat
absolutely you are amazing sorry thank
you for the super sticker I love this
little dance and pair guy I love this
that they went with pair guys in general
yeah so a big fan of Paris delicious
really appreciates it and uh yeah thank
you for being a lovely member of our
patreon as well you have been with us
for so long and uh yeah it's just been a
great joy to have you on our journey so
uh thanks buddy really appreciate you
chiming in here at the end
um and uh our last couple of stream Labs
thank you all for contributing over
there as well uh the gamer MJ me and koi
have the same top two and I heavily
respect it also koi do you have any more
comic recommendations I'm just waiting
to read Supergirl woman of tomorrow I
also have Deadpool versus the Marvel
Universe on standby oh great pools quick
rocks quick wrecks if you want to stay
in that world I would read Deadpool uh
The Good the Bad and the Ugly it's my
favorite Deadpool comic of all time it
has uh Captain American Wolverine as
well so it's it's a little Ensemble
action uh if you want to read more DC I
would check out human target which I
recommended earlier if you want to read
something a little more dark and a culty
I like Constantine but without any
continuity issues check out Department
of truth if you want to read something
really sci-fi and insane check out Saga
in general uh if you want to check out
something recent and weird as we get to
the next one I'm going to pull out my
recent loved list just to have a new
recommendation and now we're going to
get it what month is it June no it's
July when are we uh John go to the next
one and I'll have it ready all right I'm
on it
gamer MJ again oh this is perfect we can
I'll actually read this out while you
got that I read Flashpoint earlier it
was phenomenal and introduced me to
characters like element woman grifter
talk about and The Outsider among others
and question for you is uh will there be
a Killing Joke reaction coming I love
that movie
possible I feel like it may show up
somewhere in here you know yeah maybe
we'll see we'll see there's a it's
always kind of a journey figuring out
what the next one to be will be so uh I
feel like that's on the table we'll see
when it comes up you'll know from the
last week of June so very recently some
faves that are on shelves right now I'm
loving the new Batman the bray and the
Bold not to be confused with the movie
this is a very dark comic with the joker
as an actually terrifying villain
illustrated by Mr rods written by Tom
King a favorite Duo of mine who did Mr
Miracle around Batman highly recommend
also if you want something weird world
tree is only on issue three it's a new
indie from image and it's like a hyper
sex charge cyberpunk dystopian like
basically a cyber virus can invade a
person and it starts rotting the world
away and it's this really intense book
that's like pretty crazy and final wreck
over from boom uh Creed has a sequel to
the third movie set 10 years in the
future where his daughter is boxing and
it's actually so tonally in the vein of
Rocky and Michael B Jordan that it feels
like it was written like it feels like a
movie was adapted not like a comic
started it is such a good comic book The
Art's great the writing's great and it's
cool to see the Creed story continue so
uh the Creed uh has a comic from
movement scrape beautiful and Michael B
Jordan's a part of the process so it's
he's actually involved which is cool and
last but not least
Lone Wolf X thank you for you'll be
closing us out today appreciate you very
much off topic question and this is a
good off topic question have either of
you seen the bear yet if not will you be
reacting to it later uh no plans as of
yet for any kind of reactions although I
did do a free little watch along to the
one shot episode if you want to check
that out from season one uh I I gotta
start season two it's exceptional uh
then I've heard that and the first
season gripped me so
so relentlessly and so sort of
emotionally yeah I cannot wait to
continue and complete it yeah first
season establishes itself is one of the
best shows uh best new show second
season I think established is one of the
best shows absolutely oh that's good
that's High Praise I'm excited well guys
I think we have made it go check out the
bear if you haven't seen any of our DC
animated movie Universe reactions I hope
we didn't spoil them too much for you
today
um but yeah thank you all so much for
being here for leaving likes for joining
in on the Super Chat for joining in in
the actual chat and uh yeah just making
this DC animated movie Universe
experience what it has been so far
um before we get out of here just want
to give some love and thanks to all
y'all holding it down in the main chat
as well Lexington Luther good name Tita
talericki Tiana oh geez Aisha Aisha
Kenya absolutely good to see you in here
as well Angel of Death ring King keep
going with the bear Dalton made Smith
Doe lies angel of death or do we get you
already peeve Hudson County skip my
videos and I'll stop using that why did
you say that name no never I asked
probably that I asked for that are
Justice I'm gonna start doing it for
both of us James diesel Dan v900 Jason
Browning all you guys there there are
too many of you to name but we really
appreciate all of you Chris womoff uh uh
guys thank you so much for joining us on
a Sunday and uh you know uh keep wanting
to say something born on a Monday but
either way he knows what Sunday leads up
to and it vexes him leave a like on the
video if you're bored later on stream it
again and relive all the memories but
for right now thank you for being here
in the here and now keep an eye out
tomorrow for long Halloween part one
next week yeah come join us at Comic-Con
if you happen to be in San Diego and uh
yeah we'll see you next time on another
live that's probably about news or movie
spoilers why did you stream that
absolutely be well guys and we'll see
you next time much love cheers